they
was
e
ni
[Applause]
e
by
okay
here we go uh good morning um we've been
delaying starting the hearing just to
see if there was anybody running late um
I'm going to let the memb come back come
up to take their seats and then we'll
minute actually uh with this I'll open
our our day right now we will be hearing
House Bill 1660 and then later in the
afternoon we'll move across to the L for
our other bills um as we get started um
pledge
I pledge Al to the flag of the United
States of America and to the rep for it
stands one nation under God individual
all thank you very much um I would like
to open the hearing on House Bill
1660 and recognize Prime sponsor
representative Jim
kofalt
thank you madam chair um going to keep
this very brief House Bill 1660 quite
simply would
explicitly uh exclude coverage of
transgender surgery for minors in the
state of New Hampshire uh despite
statements that we've heard that it's
not happening in New Hampshire I think
in uh previous hearings before this
committee and executive sessions uh it
is quite apparent that um healthc care
providers throughout the state of New
Hampshire are at the very least
advertising such
Services
um if uh if we were to pass this we
would join 11 other states that
explicitly prohibit coverage um three of
those only explic
explicitly exclude coverage for
transgender surgery for minors the other
eight exclude transgender surgery for
all
ages um um another 12 States and three
territories have no explicit
policy that excludes that concludes my
bill introduction I'll take any
questions okay thank you uh
representative
Weber thank you madam chair and thank
you for taking my question my question
is uh when we say
um any form of gender reassignment
surgery are we talking Top surgery as
well as bottom
surgery
um yes thank you um
followup
yeah
um the other question I had was do we
know if Medicaid funds are used for uh
either breast augmentation or breast
reduction surgeries um for other
purposes I don't know the answer to that
okay thank you
thank
you rep representative Murphy great
thank you madam chairman and thank you
for taking my question
um I've heard in so many in other
settings here in the house and in
committee that these surgeries and I
think specifically they're talking about
bottom surgery is done in the state of
New
Hampshire and you just mentioned that um
at least advertised as such so do we
have any I'm trying to get a handle on
exactly what is done or not done have we
in the state of New Hampshire done any
um gender reassignment surgery and
specifically any bottom surgery not
Aesthetics and upper surgery but just
any um um uh gender reassignment surgery
under the age of 18 and any possible and
if so how can we get that information
because I hear conflicting reports and
I'm just trying to be clear about that
um thank you for the question I I don't
have access to that information so I
don't know what I do know is that in
2017 um the
DHHS implemented a policy through
rule that would authorize the state's
Medicaid Program to cover these kinds of
surgeries for um for Medicaid recipients
um this bill would
simply exclude miners from being covered
under those under that
rule
followup thank you um in and the other
question I had
was
um if if if we're not doing if are these
other surgeries
done um say Top surgery you know any you
know breast augmentations or reductions
for other medical reasons other than
transitioning surgery if they are done
in the state of New Hampshire um would
they still be covered um or not under
this bill um this bill expressly uses
the language gender
reassignment
um sex sex reassignment so just a quick
followup so that would mean to me then
um that this is
done specifically I wouldn't say
targeting but specifically for gender
reassignment including uh upper
surgery and would you agree or disagree
that that would represent discrimination
against those who may otherwise have
that surgery for for reasons other than
transitioning I would disagree I I
believe that it is uh within the purview
of the state and the state legislature
to to determine uh whether or not this
would be covered under our Medicaid
Program what's an issue here is not
whether or not these surgeries are legal
that was addressed in House Bill 619
which is going on to the Senate at this
point if House Bill 619 goes through the
Senate makes it through the Senate and
gets passed by uh gets signed by the
governor this bill would be would be
moot um so this does not address the the
legality of of that it simply says that
we as taxpayers um should not be bound
minors thank
you representative
kushman thank you madam chair and thank
you representative kofalt um are you
aware of letters that went out to miners
around 2017 alerting them to a change um
from their Managed Care Organization
under Medicaid that gen genital gender
I'm sorry gender reassignment surgery
covered um this you're you're talking
about a letter that went from the state
to I'm sorry I'm sorry can you clarify
no um and actually it was a a letter
that was addressed to um a minor child
and she was a recipient of the insurance
under the Managed Care Organization and
they they were just alerting the child's
changes in their coverage and one of the
changes was that now um because of some
rule under the ACA uh that they would be
offering this um so it was kind of
advertised to children would you believe
that I I'm not aware of that letter I
would love to see a copy of it if you
could provide me with that
representative SE King thank you madam
chair thank you representative for
taking questions um my understanding is
this bill was filed um before HB 619 was
passed that is correct in the house
would you see any Merit in passing this
bill even if HB 619 becomes signed into
law thank
you um yes I would see Merit in passing
it for for several reasons first of all
um I think that that we ought to move
forward with this
bill it I I said it was moot if House
Bill 619 passes I'm going to I'm
actually going to modify that a little
bit and say that it it is still worth
explicitly excluding uh transgender
surgery for miners from our Medicaid
coverage um in the event that the policy
established under house bill 619 were to
change whe if it were to be repealed um
that this this would still be in place
um representative actually um I'm going
to go with representative mlan since
we've already had a couple questions
from representative Murphy uh thank you
madam chair and thank you for taking my
question so there there was some
questions um with respect to the the
Dual nature of some surgeries for
example breast augmentation or breast
reduction with respect to intent um one
of them might be just because there's a
medical need uh for breast reduction
another case it might be due to gender
reassignment it administratively right
now um if you were to have something for
example a a breast reduction is there a
way to differentiate that either in the
CPT codes or anything like that between
you know this is breast reduction for
gender reassignment purposes and this is
breast reduction for other purposes or
they all fall kind of under the same
umbrella at this
point I'm I'm not an expert on medical
coding but my assumption is that yes
that those would be
um covered under separate
codes representative Murphy um thank you
once again for my question so I just
want to be clear this is only for
addressing re gender reassignment
surgery is that correct that is correct
and so my follow-up question allowed
would be that if the gender reassignment
surgery is a medically appropriate
procedure considered so in the medical
community when discussed between the
patient and the family would the next
logical extension of this bill or the
next bill coming down the road be one
where they would exclude you know um uh
the use or the treatments for hormonal
treatment um psychological treatment
Social Services treatment for these
individuals this bill does not cover any
of those does does not exclude any of
those things I agree sorry
representative I think you're asking him
to read other legislators minds and I
if you want to if you want to would you
be concerned that this might lead to uh
further um limitations on what is
considered a medically appropriate um uh
process of gender
reassignment uh my my concerns focus on
this bill and
that's that's that's the scope of the
conversation I think thank you um and
I'll actually ask a question as well
representative kofalt um would you be
willing to consider the idea of
including all um all breast procedures
both in a redu except for medically
necessary reduction because of the
weight causing back problems for other
children to exclude those surgeries for
both um transgender and for others other
children as well uh because breast
augmentation and um elective reduction
um carries risks in in the youth as well
I think an amendment that clarifies that
would be absolutely appropriate thank
you there any other questions from the
committee seeing none thank you very
much thank
you next I'll call Dr Jennifer Smith
from
Pembrook good morning Madam chair
members of the committee I appreciate
your taking testimony um as a physician
I'm retired but as a physician I spent a
career taking care of people who could
not afford regular insurance for the
most part some some could but most of my
practice ended up with being people who
are currently now more of them covered
by Medicaid and I might not have gotten
quite so poor um had I had that
opportunity during my career but my
objection to this particular bill then
leaving quite aside how you feel about
miners accessing gender related care for
transition um is the same as I had
against a bill several years ago that
tried to say that Medicaid could not
cover
circumcision there were some activists
who felt that circumcision of infant
males was a terrible thing that was
being
inflicted and wanted to have it banned
but they couldn't figure out how they
would get it banned so they brought a
ban against
Medicaid fortunately that bill bit the
dust pretty quickly because people
realized how discriminatory that
is and my concern here is part of that
slippery slope is next thing we're not
going to allow hormone treatment we're
not going to allow the other things that
are life
saving um and frankly I I don't agree
with the premise that 18 is a magic age
for deciding that after a very long time
going through gender transition you
should be prevented from going to that
step but you know that's a different
Bill and so we'll deal with that
separately but the idea that something
that is established as good
care helping people psychologically
avoid the kinds of trauma
that ends up with some health plans
quite some time ago deciding that it was
actually cheaper for the health plan to
be covering these than to have to deal
with multiple suicide attempts and
things of that nature so I really think
this bill has no place Medicaid should
cover everything frankly that any other
health plan is required to cover I don't
know the legal ins and outs of that that
but I suspect that the state would find
itself in federal court if they passed
this bill and the governor signed
it um it just doesn't make sense to me
that this bill is even being
considered thank you I don't take any
questions you might have thank you there
question uh representative Shapiro thank
um I wonder if you could comment on um
the effect on the emotional life of
transgender
people as affected by bills like this
which limit coverage but also a large
number of other bills that limit
coverage or limit procedures or
limit
um yeah limit limit procedures and limit
um services for transgender people I
wonder if you could comment on how that
affects the emotional life of people I I
think it's pretty severe um I am active
with P flag in this area and um we have
a host of families who have come through
P flag some of them have moved on and
don't need the support system but they
are really negatively impacted by these
bills their children are scared they are
scared for their children people who've
already moved from one place because of
local
opposition at the school board level and
so
forth do we have to now move out of
state you know those those kinds of
things are very real um do I know how
many of those are Medicaid covered no I
don't and I don't really think it should
matter and that's my objection to this
particular bill is it discriminates
against Medicaid covered
individuals for something that is
available potentially to others
although we've heard that it isn't
available in this state I am quite clear
it is available
elsewhere um and I frankly think it
should be um and I could go into a lot
of elaborate reasons for that but I
bill um thank you doctor I have a
question for you um my question would be
that um as a doctor you're probably
aware that most insurance coverage and
especially Medicaid is uh based on the
clinical data that supports the benefit
and speaks to the balance of risk and
benefit of a procedure I was wondering
if you could provide us any information
any any clinical information on the
safety efficacy and risks of these
procedures in minors understanding that
children aren't small adults and the
medical history of children who've
transitioned early is different than
adults that's a complicated question
because there's a whole range of people
involved but generally speaking these
are not things that are done on an
experimental basis you know the
background is years of psychological
care for things and usually if
transition is occurring fairly early in
childhood puberty blockers and then
moving onto pross sex
hormones so it's you know
since you've pushed me there I'll say
the reason I think that 18 is not a
magic age is I really feel badly for the
young transperson who has reached the
point of going to
college um and is still feeling like you
know I'm going to go to college and I'm
not able to be the same as my peers um I
just feel
that's 18 is not a magic age and in fact
we also know that the brain is still
developing in many ways right up to
about age 25 and maybe
Beyond um
judgment but you still can't just say
because judgment is not fully developed
that people shouldn't be able to make
some kinds
of choices in their life with a lot of
appropriate
guidance um you know the the age of
being responsible for your own actions
in Judaism is
Mitzvah
mitvah that's you know to me appropriate
that doesn't mean that the person goes
off and does whatever the heck they
please with guidance I think people can
make appropriate
decisions after they reach that kind of
an age and that we're certainly not
talking about gender surgery at
13 um and then as a followup I
absolutely commiserate with you about
the challenges about reimbursement and
the lack of data and the idea that you
want to make sure that this is paid for
as what you believe is life-saving care
I worked with life-saving cardiac
devices that were not covered
until I worked with life-saving cardiac
devices
sorry sorry I worked with life-saving
cardiac devices that were not covered by
Medicaid or insurers without data if you
could provide any data about this in
this population to the committee I'd
really appreciate it I know that you've
spoken about it but I'd love it if you
could email anything that you have for
us I think it's a different bill that
you're been addressing because that bill
I guess has already gone over to the
Senate and I'm I'm reluctant without
doing sitting down and doing a lot of
up-to-date research um I I do that kind
of thing when I need to I have not done
that yet on that particular issue um I I
know that in the past there has not been
a question about that and the major
medical
organizations from the American Academy
of
Pediatrics and all of the psychological
organizations and Psychiatry
organizations don't see this as being
something that's problematic so thank
you okay representative B King and then
representative
missor thank you madam chair and uh
thank you for taking my question
since you're a doctor and and you've
also talked about the age of 18 being um
questionable on whether uh that's the GU
the set guideline that we should use I
was wondering if you could elaborate a
little bit on brain development and how
many brains aren't especially male
brains aren't fully developed until
25 I I don't know that there's use in in
elaborating that I it's true um there's
no question about it I look back on
myself before I reached my mid 20s and I
wonder how I survived you know I that's
I think that's common knowledge now I
don't know that I I could elaborate on
it I'm I'm a family physician you know
my interests are wide I also have a
public health degree and I you know I've
read a lot of stuff but am I an expert
on brain development is going through
adolescence
no thank you representative missor and
then representative Weber yes thank you
madam chair thank you for taking my
question so to clarify because I'm still
unsure are you saying that um gender
transition surgery should be covered by
Medicaid at any
age if it were covered by other
insurance
yes at any age if that were a decision
that had come down for other insurance
yes but that decision has not come down
at any age and I don't think it
will you know I think the transition
procedure is
long the notion that people are doing
surgery on young children is just wrong
it doesn't
happen follow up well yeah thank you for
taking my followup so I know several
people who are in the process of
actually detransitioning should there
should there should that be covered for
them as
well I I would think so at any age I
think anyone who is in need of medical
services and has appropriate Medical
Care and psychological care should be
allowed to access that care absolutely
thank you representative Weber and then
representative
kushman thank you madam chair and thank
you for taking my question the
microphones are a little peculiar so I'm
trying to find the right spot
um would you agree with me that as a
followup to your point about 18 not
being a magic age that there may be a
child at
17 who had been for many years
undergoing the spectrum of care that
comes with a
transition who might well be able to
consent with the consent of their
parents to a particular procedure where
we're we all know 25y olds who shouldn't
have care of a goldfish um but that
there is a spectrum and each person
falls at a different spot on that
Spectrum based on their own makeup based
on the quality of Family Care they have
had based on the quality of mental
health and physical health care that
they have had and they arrive at the
right point in different ways by very
different
means I couldn't say it better than you
just
said Thank You representative kushman
thank you madam chair thank you for
taking my question um so as a doctor do
you agree that um an adult who has gone
through puberty and has completed their
um their growth in their genital area
and all of the tissue development that
comes with that after
puberty um that a surgery to take that
tissue and change it into something else
is a lot different on a minor or a young
person who has had puberty blockers and
uh cross- seex hormones that have
contributed to atrophy or uh an absence
of development of that tissue do you see
how that is novel to be and and it's
breaking ground to do such
surgeries as they're very different from
adults you know it's an interesting
question and I have got a little tiny
bit of information that I've heard from
people and I know nothing more about
that and and I don't think the
legislature should get into the business
of trying to legislate the minutia of
what's appropriate medical
care that's what we have all of our
specialty societies for there are
malpractice laws you know I think you're
asking something that I cannot
reasonably answer nor do I think it is
germine to whether or not you should
exclude Medicaid coverage of something
that other insurance has decided is
okay a
followup thank you
um respectfully if if there's no data
and we have such a difference in the
procedures and how they're done on a on
a patient I didn't say you you put that
word in my mouth that there's no data I
did not say that I said I am not that
familiar with it
okay um well experimental care as I see
it I didn't say that either actually I I
think we'll probably stop that line of
questioning because I I recognize that
you don't have that area of knowledge
and we can pursue that uh representative
mlan thank you madam chairman thank you
for taking my question I just want to
follow up a little bit on uh some of the
concerns you express with respect to the
the legal Jeopardy uh that the state May
puts himself in something like this was
to go forward are you aware of any other
states that have similar
legislation um and have been exposed to
um some of the legal Jeopardy that
you're concerned
about no I'm not certain about that I
think it probably is happening I know
there are suits around transgender
issues for laws that have outlawed
transition care specifically Medicaid I
have not heard whether that true or not
I I just can't imagine that there
litigation seeing no further questions
thank you very much doctor for your
testimony and with that I have my last
pink card in my hand if there's anybody
else who would wanted to speak please
get that to me before we're done here
and I'd like to represent uh Louise
Spencer from the Kent Street
Coalition hi thank you madam chair and
thank you uh to the committee for taking
my testimony today my name is my name is
Louise Spencer I'm from conquered New
Hampshire and I am uh the co-founder of
the Ken Street Coalition which is an all
volunteer Grassroots advocacy
organization um and I am here speaking
on my own behalf but also on behalf of
the Coalition uh we believe strongly
that people deserve access to the
healthc care that they need and um we
also believe strongly that
that decision is best left between a
patient and their physician and in this
instance between a minor child their
parents and a
physician um
and it's it's in their best interest
it's best to have them determine what's
in their best
interest
um
so we also believe that people who would
other otherwise be able to access care
should not be treated differently just
because they happen to be on Medicaid
there are all kinds of reasons that
people end up on Medicaid and to treat
people differently and to create
barriers that otherwise do not exist is
is
unfair um this bill is just one of many
that have been focused on transgender
youth in particular we we've seen
another number of bills focused on
transgender people in general but the
the trend seems to be on transgender
youth I've talked to many parents and
some youth about the pain they are
feeling of having to repeatedly come
before this body to justify their
existence and their medical needs and
this bill
forces his people to do that very
thing
um again I can't stress just how
important it is that doctors and
patients and parents are best suited to
know exactly what would bring somebody
to the
point where they think that this is the
next step that they need to take for
their overall health for their Mental
Health
um for their psychosocial
health I'm not impressed by how many
other states may or may not be doing
this we've seen
instances over and over again when
states have had very misguided policies
we saw that when states
banned um interracial marriage between
the in the early half of the uh 20th
century I think over 30 States out of 48
actively enforced those
laws that did not make them right so the
idea that other states are doing this
does not in any way make it right
furthermore I am used to New Hampshire
and have always been proud of New
Hampshire for being a leader on issues
and not a follower and
increasingly it looks to me like we have
been a follower on these issues in 2018
we were a leader we adopted an
anti-discrimination
bill that recognized the inherent human
dignity of all Granite
Staters we are going backward here and
we're going backward because we're
taking the lead from some national
states I think that New Hampshire should
be a leader and not a follower and that
we should lead with
courage and
compassion we should be focused on what
this state needs and who our people are
and this bill goes against that so I
urge you please itl this bill please and
Restore New Hampshire as a leader thank
you thank you questions from the
committee representative Missour thank
you madam chair thank thank you for
taking my question so I am pretty
disappointed to not see any healthc care
providers here today because I would
have I would ask them this question
because we were told previous by
previously by them that gender
transition surgery on minors is not
happening in our state is that what you
think is happening as well is it not
happening or do you see it happening I'm
not a health care provider and I really
you don't I wouldn't presume to speak um
issue having attended a good number of
hearings where doctors have spoken I'm
aware that it's the rare
instance excuse me where um particularly
any sort of bottom surgery would be
um the the step taken um but I I can't I
I can't address your
your question I'm sure there are healthc
care providers that would be willing to
um address that outside of this hearing
with you though thank you Unfortunately
you um I have a question for you um are
you do you know if there are other
procedures that are covered by insurance
and by Medicaid simply by the fact that
a medical society has included them in
their protocols and clinical guidelines
if you think about cancer or cardiac I'm
not sure I understand the question can
you frame it my question is just because
the doctors and the medical societies
think something is good like some cancer
treatment or some heart disease
treatment do you believe that all of
those either are or should automatically
be covered by
Medicaid it's usually not based just on
what the medical society says um I my
husband is a physician and I I did a lot
of billing um I worked for his practice
um it's rarely based solely on the
recommendation of the medical
society um it in it's a very
complex um set of factors that are
determined about when a procedure is
covered or not it has to do with
diagnosis codes it does have to do with
whether something is considered
experimental or not
um it has to do with um repetition of
procedures I mean there are many factors
that can come into play there are also
appeal procedures so that things that
might not be routinely covered are in
fact covered when it is necessary for
the medical um health and well-being of
a person so there there are no kind of
formulas that can be applied um across
the board that would say yes or no um we
have certain procedures you know if
they've been found um to
be um you know I'm trying to
think I was going to say applying
leeches probably wouldn't be allowed but
now that's in fact used for
anti-coagulation so I won't opine on
that but uh what I will say is that it
is a very complex determination often
with many
levels that patients can appeal to in
order to get the care that they need um
including experimental procedures in
fact thank
you representative Missour yeah thank
you for taking another question um so
you mentioned that you worked in
Billing and so did you see or the codes
that were used for bottom surgeries top
surgeries Etc no
my husband did not practice in that
field of medicine did were you aware
they were in
existence um I W I wasn't I mean it just
wasn't my area Okay of I I had no reason
to to do that and also our the practice
has been closed now for about eight
years so okay thank you uh thank you uh
thank you very much for speaking with us
today and I want to thank everybody who
was here today I know we may have asked
a few questions that were outside of
your normal Lane but wanted to make sure
that we could have the best
understanding we could uh given that the
turnout was not what I think any of us
expected for today um so with that I'd
like to thank for everybody who is here
and everybody who is watching on the
live stream and with that I will close
the hearing on House Bill
1660 thank you the next thing that the
house that the um Health and Human
Services committee will be doing is at
1:00 over on the lob as noticed in the
calendar so thank
you
what's a moment to catch his breath oh
okay
I am ready thank you for your patience
hey um again welcome everyone to the
house committee on Health and Human
Services and elderly
Affairs uh we have a number of public
hearing scheduled for this afternoon the
first one being House Bill
1693 uh the prime sponsor representative
Kevin verville is unable to be here this
afternoon but in his place is
Representative Keith Ammon welcome
representative Ammon thank you uh good
afternoon Health and Human Services
committee uh I was asked by uh the good
and honorable good friend of mine
representative Kevin verville to
introduce this interesting Bill uh
before you to this committee and he sent
me a prepared statement uh that I have
in front of me I'm just going to read
the statement um and I'll I'll begin
I'll I'll be
quick I'll read word for word good
afternoon I am Representative Keith
adman representing Hillsboro 42 and
filling in for representative verville
as he cannot be here today I'm here to
present House Bill 1693 and act relative
to the use of psychedelics for
therapeutic purposes this bill is
modeled off of our medical cannabis laws
it allows for the medical use of
lysergic acid diethyl
diethylamide LSD
musculine the active in North American
peyote Cactus and silos cybin the active
in North American magic mushrooms our
medical cannabis program has been
running successfully without issue for
several years now it is a proven model
of success this bill looks to expand
upon that success by including more
substances these substances have been
shown time and again since the 1950s to
be remarkably effective for the
treatment of alcoholism drug addiction
particularly narcotic addiction
depression including forms of treatment
resistant to depression PTSD and fear of
death among terminally ill persons to
name the most common and best studied in
fact it has been shown that in a
majority of patients just one quote high
dose end quote treatment is all that is
required for successful
treatment these are not substances
intended for long-term therapeutic use
although no harm has ever been observed
from repe repeated treatment these
substances are non-addictive non-habit
forming and have an interesting self
mechanism to prevent abuse the more
often that one consumes these
traditional psychedelics the lesser the
effect on the user this also holds true
for increasing the dosage if one uses
psychedelics too often then the effects
are lost even if larger dosages are
taken the only way for a person to
regain the effects of these substances
is to not use them for a period of time
few of any other drugs have this effect
on people the only counter indicator for
application of these
compounds is for persons predisposed to
SK schizophrenia as it can trigger it
onset these substances were placed on
the FDA schedule one in the late
1960s as a knee-jerk reaction to social
upheaval occurring at that time make no
mistake about it we are against the
expansion of availability of dangerous
and highly addictive substances like
amphetamines barbituates narcotics Andor
opioids
psychedelics have nothing in common with
these types of substances and moral
them we are aware that there are some
that have concerns about patients using
these substances without immediate
medical
supervision we contend that it is a
decision best made by practitioners and
their patients there is nothing in this
bill that would prohibit a practitioner
to mandate that the patient used these
substances under direct medical
supervision or under a more clinical
setting than
home in fact we believe that this would
be the most common form of prescription
at least during the first or early
treatments further it is not
unfathomable to imagine that all
practitioners May insist on use only
under clinical settings again these are
decisions best left to medical
professionals and their
patients it is important to note that
among these compounds LSD is the only
compound that is a man-made synthetic
compound still tightly controlled by
federal law and therefore would not be
available for use except under special
permit by the
FDA there are currently several groups
in the USA with limited permits for LSD
mesculin and
psilocybin peyote only grows naturally
in the desert Southwest of the United
States and therefore would have limited
to no application in the short
term magic mushrooms grow naturally in
all 50 states and are easily grown
indoors making psilocybin the most
likely candidate for treatment in the
short term in New Hampshire similar to
cannabis
today this bill is a common sense harm
reduction expansion of our current
expanded medical treatment options in
New Hampshire given the proven track
record of our medical cannabis bill this
is a logical continuation of that Legacy
in an effort to provide help and
treatment to those most in need in a
safe and secure manner we respectfully
ask that the committee recommend this
ought to pass thank
you thank you are you taking questions
or I could take the question and and let
you know whether or not I have an answer
okay representative Lon uh thank you Mr
chairman and thank you representative
Ammon for filling in on short notice uh
my question is if you're aware that the
veterans ass uh Veterans Administration
is pursuing psilocybin for PTSD and um
that whether if this would be something
that if we were to pass it or study it
to better tailor it to its needs that
this legislation would be needed in
order to open up the potential for
psilocybin for PTSD in our veteran
population thank you for the question
I'm not intimately familiar with the
matter um but uh I have met veterans who
had PTSD and use psychedelics to treat
their PTSD there's a there's a group
called maps
maps I can't remember what the what it
stands for but it it's it was the
representative of that organization whom
I met I think it was in rested in
Virginia at one point um was a veteran
had PTSD experienced a very traumatic
event in battle and was an advocate for
uh doing what this legislation would do
so thank you representative
McLean thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question so one of the
things that you talked about which is
different from the Cannabis is the
Cannabis is more of a long-term kind of
thing and you know you mentioned the
fact that the the therapy that would
involve this kind of treatment would be
high dose and in fact over extended
period uh the effects kind of wean away
so what the bill does is it says it kind
of looks like it's setting up a registry
where you have a registry card since you
know you wouldn't be looking at having
like a long-term thing like cannabis
would you be happy with just having the
ability to prescribe um the drug in
these conditions you know on a limited
basis as opposed to having a registry
card or do you think that you need to
have the registry card thank you for the
question I just want to make it clear I
don't think I'm a sponsor on this bill
I'm pretty sure I'm not um and the words
that I read were written for me by the
prime sponsor so those were not my exact
words although I I share some of the
sentiments um to answer your question
I'm not an expert in this field but the
the mind is a mysterious organ right and
sometimes it gets because of traumatic
events uh you know seeing your buddies
uh killed in war or some other childhood
trauma it gets locked in a certain state
right it's a it's a it's a neural
network and neural networks can get
locked in something called a local
Minima that's kind of like a computer
science term but it gets locked in a
state that it can't break out of on its
own and what these drugs do in my
understanding my Layman's understanding
is they sort of allow it to establish
allow your brain to establish new types
of connections to sort of like get out
of that that stuck State and based on
what was written for me it sounds like
it only needs uh potentially only needs
a few treatments as you mentioned um but
but I think the important thing is it
has to be guided by a professional right
you need someone there with you in the
room so that if you experience a
frightening event you know reliving some
traumatic event that there's someone
there who's experienced on how to handle
that so that that would be
uh the way I would understand it follow
up thank you and so I recognize you're
not uh the prime sponsor and so maybe
you're not but it sounds like then that
you would be you don't necessarily need
the registry card as long as I have the
ability to prescribe it and if I want to
manner uh that's how I understand it I I
understand it the same way that you do
yeah sentive Weber thank you Mr chairman
and thank you uh this is more of a would
you believe question would you believe
that the problem with having providers
prescribe is that prescribe licensed
providers can't prescribe these things
because it is illegal for them to do so
and they would like to keep their
license which is why the Cannabis
program was set up that the licensed
provider certifies the exist existence
of a
condition and it is the provider of the
Cannabis or in this case the substance
that then deals with the issue of type
and dosage and all the rest of it
because the providers can't do that
would would you be interested to learn
that I would be interested to learn that
thank you um and and it makes it jogs
thoughts in in my um mind too that we
see when we go to uh Manchester or even
in conquered we we have a homeless
problem and some of those homeless
people have mental issues and some of
those mental issues are from tra trauma
you maybe they were veterans um if if
there is a way to treat their condition
in a clinical setting and and you know
provide relief in a short term maybe
some of those people could become more
uh functional members of society um and
there there is some evidence out there
that an approach like this may help help
some people
so representative
Merchant thank you Mr chairman also
thank you
representative taking the
question in regards to trying to
establish another oversight board what
are your thoughts
on having the existing cannabis board
become the body that sort of oversees
this versus trying to create another um
government um another government agency
if you will I think that that sounds
like a fine idea to um to not create new
bureaucracy but you know repurpose
existing I like that idea and again this
this is just my personal thoughts um
I'll be voting on this bill just like
you you will I'm just giving you my my
opinions that's all follow up if I could
also in regards to following up repesent
of Weber um I do think the use of it in
a clinical setting makes a lot of sense
but to follow on representative Weber's
comment is the legality of it is that if
you get into a clinic whether it's
prescribed or through a drug order you
run into the same issue where a licensed
provider really can't order the product
through their licenser licenser if you
will so it does cause a problem but I
think the intent of having some
supervision of the patient makes a lot
of
sense would you believe I would believe
that uh I mentioned I may not be able to
pull it up here quickly but um there are
are experts out there who are working on
this issue and working on state
legislation I mentioned the organization
maps
maps uh I can't pull up their website
right now but um they would be able to
answer those questions that you have I'm
questions representative
McKay thank you Mr
chairman um you probably can't answer
this uh question the the implication of
this
legislation is that this is a
therapeutic
useful approach uh to particularly to
mental health uh do you know what that's
based on who did the research and any
Publications that could
verify my my day was that this was a
terrible um one of my fellow students at
but became quite famous for his use of
that was it Timothy Larry was that your
student right that so that I'm curious
as to how this is full of legal
protections and what police can do and
can't do but that I I don't see
any information as to how they arrived
therapeutic thank you for the question
I'm not a clinical you know scientist
I'm a substitute for the presenter of
this bill so um I found the website for
maps it's maps.org maps.org there's a
lot of information there one thing I do
know um we're our state is on the border
of Canada and Canada has legalized
psychedelic drugs there's there's a
whole
industry of um you you can purchase
their stock on the Canadian stock market
if you want there's a whole industry of
drug companies who have these novel
psychedelic drugs that are being
approved in Canada for the purposes that
we're talking about so it's not a
far-fetched
idea and there's there's maybe there's
at least a dozen companies in
Canada that's just based on my knowledge
Bank another question uh representative
Shapiro this is a question of the chair
do we have other people um schedule to
testify that might um be able to respond
to more of the technical aspects to the
bill no one else is submitted a pink
card no okay thank
you I B you do thank
you thank
you uh no one has indicated a preference
on the blue sheet either um oh oh okay
sure
absolutely
um bill brigh has signed up to speak
from the New Hampshire State Police on
HB
1693 put your microphone there you go
good afternoon thank you for uh hearing
my testimony uh as you stated my name is
Bill brigh I'm uh with the New Hampshire
State Police the major of the uh
Investigative Services Bureau um I just
wanted to uh speak up on this on this
bill I've read through it uh once a
while back my understanding is is that
this would allow for the use of
psychedelics not only in a clinical
setting but outside of a clinical
setting that raises some public safety
concerns for us um as in psychedelics
are known the reactions to psychedelics
are known to be unpredictable um nobody
knows how they're going to react to them
until uh they start using them which is
uh very concerning even you could get a
different reaction
a different time that you that you uh
use a psychedelic drug as in if you took
it in a clinical setting had one
reaction you may not react the same way
the next time uh that you take a a
similar dose um that's obviously
concerning for many different reasons
the um concerns would be access to uh
juveniles underage people um are the
safety on our roads uh with the
unpredictable reactions to these drugs
um would bring a lot of concerns as well
as just uh whoever whoever comes into
contact with somebody having a bad
reaction to these drugs um would there
would be some safety concerns with that
so those were those were the things that
I just wanted to to bring up is that I
believe after reading through the bill I
believe that this allows for the use of
psychedelics outside of a clinical
setting which is not exactly what it
sounded like when the um when they
testified
previously representative Weber
thank you for your testimony and thank
you for taking my question do you know
if you know what are the uh laws in the
states surrounding us the other New
England states on the use of
psychedelics I'm not familiar with the
other states I'll have to do my own
research thank you it is a schedule one
drug so I imagine that it's very similar
to New Hampshire everywhere
representative Leon and then
representative Shapiro um thank you Mr
chairman and thank you very much for
being here it's good to see you again um
my question was would be if we were to
refer this to interim study to try to
figure out how to enable places like
some of the hospitals to our South that
have established programs for
Massachusetts residents to use it or the
VA to do that would you be willing to
collaborate with us if we were to
interum study this and try and make sure
that we don't trigger any law
enforcement concerns while trying to see
that there may be an access for some
well-controlled clinical clinical work
with some of these underserved
communities yeah certainly willing to be
accessible for consultation and and to
collaborate I just I can't guarantee
that uh we're going to recommend at any
point that we would you know encourage
uh legalization of psychedelics thank
you representative Shapiro thank you Mr
chairman um you um may be the expert on
this bill um you're certainly a few
steps ahead of me because I haven't read
the whole thing
um do you know where in the bill it
talks about
what would what a clinical setting would
be would look like it like I said it's
been a while since I read it because I
believe I I read it back when it was uh
coming to us for the um fiscal impact um
so it's been a it's been a while since
I've been through it but my my uh
recollection then was that um it talked
about uh psychedelics in a clinical
setting and outside of a clinical
setting some of the language right at
the beginning
um
a qualifying patient shall not be
subject to arrest by state or local law
enforcement prosecution or penalty under
state or Municipal law be in violation
of RSA 38b or denied any writ or
privilege for the therapeutic use of
psychedelics and according with this
chapter what page are you on Sir uh it's
page
four yeah if the qualifying patient
possesses an amount of psychedelics that
does not exceed the following in it and
it lists up to 2 ounces so that's
suggesting that law enforcement would
come in contact with a person in
possession of psychedelics and that to
me says it's outside of a clinical
setting just in that first
paragraph thank you representative
Merchant thank you Mr chair and also
thank you
uh official title is uh major or yeah
major sorry thank you
sir I share your concern about drugs
being used utiliz in the capacity
outside of a clinical setting and then
creating a problem with Public
Safety are you aware of any test that
can be taken or administered to a
patient or to a individual that you
think is under the influence of this
drug to document in fact there is a
correlation between like we do with
alcohol that they're over a certain
limit uh so we have drug recognition
experts um they're uh trained individual
ual within our agency and many law
enforcement agencies throughout the
state that are able to evaluate people
um under the influence of whatever of
Narcotics and and they can usually label
a you know a they can say they're under
the influence of a a narcotic or an
opioid or um uh psychedelic potentially
based on how their body reacts or what
they're seeing during the the evaluation
I'm not an expert so I I can't
necessarily give you the exact uh terms
that are used but um I'm not aware of
anything that would allow anyone to
gauge the level that they are
impaired the level of that would be in
their system we can we can tell when
somebody's impaired but beyond that
that's difficult to
determine so I understand it correctly
it's observational yes not okay thank
you representative McLean did you have
your hand up earlier yes thank thank you
Mr chair um there was testimony earlier
that um uh these substances have been
approved for recreational use in Canada
so definitely I think outside of a
clinical setting um are are you aware of
any concerns raised you know by law
enforcement in Canada any issues um that
have followed uh from uh that
legalization I have not uh collaborated
with anybody in any Canadian authorities
to to Det determin that um so I don't
have any specific information on that I
I imagine there's similar concerns with
uh Public Safety at times due to that
drug representative Lon um thank you Mr
chairman and thank you major for taking
another question um is there does there
need to be a certain per se level of
intoxication of any substance in order
for somebody to be arrested and
convicted of driving Under the Influence
impairment to any degree I believe is
the term that is used so that's that's
an evaluation and then can be followed
up with chemical tests uh later on but
impairment to any degree is the term
that is used follow up follow um and
then as a followup you don't need any
actual tested level in order to obtain a
conviction would that be correct are you
talking for alcohol or for any for any
of the drugs considering that we I I
assume that we're arresting people for
DUI of all sorts of
substances yes it's impairment to any
degree if the evidence shows that that a
person is impaired
uh while they're driving a motor vehicle
then yes you can secure a conviction
that way thank you representative McLean
and just to follow up on that question
um the impairment is determined through
a sobriety a field sobriety test or
something of that nature or how is that
determined yeah it starts with field
sobriety tests and then as I said we
have drug recognition experts it and
that goes further than the the normal
roadside field sobriety tests that
somebody has to agree to that testing
and uh agree to uh the evaluation by a
drug recognition expert just like they
would agree to have their blood drawn
for Chemical Testing somebody any
anybody can refuse that um
evaluation other
questions seeing none okay thank you
thank
you no one else has signed up to testify
an b693 does anyone else wish to
testify seeing no one uh I'm going to
close the public hearing on oh I have
the online data okay there were six
people who signed in in support three
that opposed and one that were neutral
online and no one uh indicated any
preferences on the blue sheet in the
back so I'm going to close the public
hearing on HB
1693 and open the public hearing on HB
168 well maybe by one minute wait a
minute one minute
okay in one minute we will open the next
public hearing you mind if I ask Lucy if
we have
time
cities
la
there's there's only 10 copies of um
testimony for HD 1585 it's not testimony
it's a a recommended
copies okay I'd like to open the public
hearing at this time on HB 1585 and
represent and and representative how do
I pronounce your last name groy or grot
grot gr okay thank you um recognize
welcome thank you my name is Jackie groa
I'm a state representative representing
Rockingham 24 the towns of Ry in
Greenland I submitted this bill with the
um assisted living facilities with
medication
distribution um and I want we we're
trying to use the same model that lnaas
used to become an
n& however during the conver
conversations with several stakeholders
it appears that the bill as written does
not address the concern or the request
and um meeting with them a couple at
least twice we came to get we we all
decided that a a study committee might
be the best way to handle this issue so
for example in assisted living
facilities individuals who have
capability to take their own medication
can do so on their own but if they have
an issue with taking the cap off the
bottle or if they have Tremors and they
need help with a glass of water there is
only a nurse or an LNA can can help them
there is there the a personal care
assistant which knows this person
closely because they work with them
every day cannot help them because it's
not part of the rules so originally we
had thought that if we Exempted these
facilities from U this requirement
similar to what we do with DD facilities
it would be helpful however it's not so
easy because often times residential
these Residential Care Facilities that
there their as they're called have
different levels of care so it's not a
clearcut kind of it's not a clear-cut um
decision
so we got I we all as a together as a
group put together this recommendation
for a study committee that we're hoping
you'll adopt so that we can be helpful
to the community there are people here
who can speak to their situation and the
um the problem at hand but I'll take any
questions that the committee might have
okay thank you representative
Weber thank you Mr chairman and thank
you than you for taking my question is
it is it also um true that one of the
moving parties behind this legislation
was County nursing homes and that the
regulations get more complicated as the
as the capacity of the patient
gets
less that's right okay that's right so
that that would be one of the things
that would be studied it would be would
it be the the levels of care it would be
the levels of care and the rules that
apply to these levels of care are also a
bit
complicated and could do some teasing
out thank you representative
Merchant thank you Mr there but this is
probably a question for our
parliamentarian what's really the
difference between an interim study
versus a study committee in a sense that
if we create an interim study we still
have a committee get together to to
study it where we create another
committee I'm just trying to understand
it's a matter of timing timing we could
actually refer the bill to interim study
and if people are willing to study it um
then they can certainly do that uh and a
report would be done by the end of you
know whenever our deadlines are they're
in the calendar I just don't remember
it's October and uh published in the the
house uh Journal it there's no further
action taken on the bill because we're
at the end of the legislative session uh
with respect to a study committee that
would report and traditionally they
report about
November and again they would make a
report that would not go in the house
calendar because it's just a report and
then anybody who wants to file leg in
either case let anybody who wants to
file legislation next time around gets
to do that um so I mean you know we can
debate endlessly between study
committees and interim study but if I
might add the the um the document that I
sent to you it's a recommended amendment
is only start it's only a starting point
but I do include all the or um
stakeholders that have been involved
with the discussion so far and that has
been very
beneficial good I sure representative
wber so if I could go further into the
structure of something um if we name all
of these people it's a commission not a
study committee and that does get into
the problem of getting it together and
and all of our rules about
commissions um the other thing that I
think is very relevant in this is if
it's interim study it's only members of
this committee that are studying it if
we do a legislative study committee then
we can um bring in folks from Health and
Human Services from Ed and which deals
with licensing and perhaps Commerce
which deals with insurance and that
might be a more effective way of looking
at it and if we then it appears to me I
haven't been able to read all of this
but if you have three house members and
two senate members and the Senate will
reduce that to one um you could set up
that committee with the recommendation
that they consult with including but not
limited to the people who have already
expressed an
interest thank you thank you for the
Indulgence Mr chair sure representative
L on you had some information uh yes
thank you Mr chairman the interim study
reports are due October 25th which is
one week exactly before the deadline in
the proposed um special subcommittee
right so I didn't ask for an interim
study this is actually for a committee a
study committee because I felt that
members of the Edna committee would be
important to have and I um would offer
myself to that study committee to
this other
questions other comments okay thank you
thank
you also signed up to speak is Gary
Arch
yes
okay sure
okay Sarah NATO from uh Carriage Hill
Assisted
Living can you press the button
please Mr chairman and members of the
committee I thank you for the
opportunity to speak today we have a
little flexibility in our schedule so
you know usually we ask people to keep
it to three minutes I can give you more
than that but try to keep it under the
10 though absolutely thank
you so my name is Sarah NATO and I'm the
owner and the administrator of carael
Assisted Living we're a 24 bed facility
in Madbury and this bill is something
that has come to fruition through
several meetings starting last July um I
also am the Secretary of New Hampshire
Arch the association of Residential Care
Homes and we had the opportunity to work
with DHHS to do a rules review over the
the summer and much of this came forth
from a review of those rules the area of
the largest concern and uh areas was
medication administration and so this
bill is to look at those rules
specifically only for HP 804 and HP 805
Assisted Living residences so this would
not affect nursing homes only HP 804 and
805 we are Residential Care Homes we are
the home of our residents and the the
goal is always to keep people in a
residential care setting as opposed to
nursing home or hospital level care um
to the fullest extent possible the
concern is that the current rules
through the Board of Nursing that
licensees staff who are permitted to
pass medication have to cover multiple
settings hospitals nursing homes and
residential care and they
are absolutely appropriately more
restrictive given that those lentur do
have um opportunity to work in those
different settings so where it would be
inappropriate in my opinion for an LNA
to pass medication in a hospital I do
feel that with appropriate training we
are Residential Care setting and the
rules should be somewhat different for
us as opposed to hospitals or nursing
homes because they do deal with a higher
level of Acuity currently the staff who
are permitted by lawn roll to administer
medication in our setting are only RN
LPN
or m&as m&as are medication nursing
assistants so they are lnas who have
gone for additional training for a
certification um and then they have a
secondary license called a medication
nursing assistant
license the concern is that we have a
significant work for Staffing issue and
while it affects all levels of
employment all career paths within our
organizations one of the areas hardest
hit is those who are able to pass
medication the RN LPN and m&as that is
where a majority of our facilities have
struggled the most with Staffing in the
last fiveish years 14 homes have closed
in New Hampshire with the primary reason
being a shortage of Staffing and at the
end of the day it is really a patient
safety issue we need to have enough
Staffing and appropriately trained
Staffing to make sure we are safely
administering medication but there are
significant barriers within the rules as
representative grotus said as far as our
ability to even assist people to take
off the Caps of bottles to take their
their medication um but those barriers
to train there are also barriers to
training to be an LNA um or once you
obtain your LNA license which has you
know a cost to obtain that training
current rules require them LNA to work
for two years full-time before they can
apply to take the medication nursing
assistant Class A lot of our population
is transient mean they do not stay
longterm and by by that it's not
negative I have some of my best staff
are high schoolers who came out of
votech programs who obtained their LNA
license they have broader career paths
many of them are College Bound and are
only working for us to gain experience
while they're in high school or in
college we also have a lot of nursing
students and so to spend the time and
the money to obtain a lure when they're
on a higher level career path um does
not make sense for them but they may
work for example my Organization for
three to 5 years anding during that time
I feel they are very appropriate to be
eligible for that medication
administration training but do not have
the time or the money and the resources
on top of further education to invest in
that while they're simultaneously
pursuing Advanced degrees so while that
not may not be all of the staff involved
in this those barriers and time
constraints and cost of getting the
additional licenses takes a significant
pool of the workforce that would be very
capable with training to administer
medic ation it is problematic and
they're not able to do that so part of
what we're looking at with this is to
remove some of the barriers to receive
the appropriate
training having said that I think study
is the best path forward because we've
been meeting on this many of the
stakeholders and noted as part of the
recommended folks to be part of this
committee um we all recognize that this
is a problem that there are safety
concerns I am very optimistic with us
meeing that we all have a fundamental
belief that this is a significant
problem with the Aging New Hampshire
population the shortage of work for
Staffing limit numbering of nursing home
beds that we have to address this issue
to keep people appropriate the most
appropriate level of care but the
barriers to them obtaining the proper
training and certification is
problematic so I am very much in favor
of this bill I'm optimistic that with
those stakeholders we can come up with a
solution that everyone is comfortable
with and we can put forth a solid Bill
next year
here thank you representative
Shapiro thank you Mr chair um I I
understand you're recommending that it
go to a study committee but um going
back to the original bill um and you
gave quite a few reasons why it hasn't
worked to
um to depend on medic I don't remember
the acronym but medication is medication
the m&a m& m& yes medication nursing
assistance um but would the lnas who
were able to administer these
medications or help people take their
medications would they receive some
lesser but still some kind of training
that Beyond went beyond the regular
LNA so if I'm understanding your
question correctly um I just want to
make sure I'm understanding what you're
getting to so the lnas primarily their
role in our facilities to help with
grooming toileting um dressing and so
forth they are not currently permitted
to administer medication other than to a
particular cohort if they are able to
accept nurse delegation and receive
appropriate training so there is a
potential for them to receive nurse
delegation and pass medication but they
cannot pass to the entire building uh so
it doesn't necessarily help with our
staffing
situation in the sense that if you have
um you have to have an RN or an LPN also
on site at the same time even if they're
assisting through nurse
delegation so um to answer your question
if I'm trying to get to it correctly so
the lnas do a different role than those
passing
medication so they the LNA would have to
go for further education to get that m&a
license on top of their LNA license to
be able to administer
medication so we have several options
that we need to explore to determine how
best to move forward with that training
um whether it is uh reducing the time
requirement before they can take the m&a
or are we going to look at a different
path where um an LNA tract is different
than an m& track and they can choose
either career path I'm not sure what the
ultimate recommendation would be but
that's why we need to take it further to
study did that answer your question sir
follow follow up um I can I can see why
it needs further study yeah it is
complicated
yes representative
Merchant thank you Mr
chair this is probably more a question
to the chair than to the person
testifying I see that this is really
important um if we go through a study
committee if I understand the
legislative
calendar this is going to be a report
that comes out sometime in October
November then we have to have
legislation again
next fall work on it next winter and
hopefully get something in the law maybe
by the summer of
2025 is there any possibility if this is
not an early Bill to have a subcommittee
to come together and try to work on this
this is not early bill so I mean if we
have time we trying to get to in order
to try to meet the calendar this time
and get something in place by the summer
of the Fall is having people in the
subcommittee meeting with the
stakeholders and try to draft something
that may make sense versus waiting a
whole
year this is not an early bill from what
I right so we we'd have until what March
15th I think March
14th I think is the deadline to report
by March 21st March 21st so we have we
have a month and a half or so I thought
it
was I don't I think it is no this is not
an early Bill okay so I guess it would
be the call of the the chair again also
by the stakeholders whether there' be
enough interest in trying to work on
this during that period of time to come
up with an amendment to the bill to make
something viable you're you're
subcommittee I will volunteer for a sub
there so I'm I'm looking again at the
original Bill and I'm I'm not
understanding
why this Administration is already
allowed it's already in
statute um for people who are caring for
people in the
community and so
I'm I'm wondering why it's so
difficult to have it also exist in
treatment fac and Care Facilities where
there is more supervision rather than
less
supervision that seems counterintuitive
to me and I I I was hoping you could
just help me with that underlying issue
because it seems to me that there's more
supervision
available and therefore less risk of
something going horribly wrong in the
residential Set uh setting rather than
setting so in having met the last two
weeks with some of the stakeholders I
think the concern is that many of us
based on the cuity of care of our
residents we do go through end of life
so you do have people who are in Hospice
at end of life who are are physically
unable cognitively unable at end of life
to take their own medication so we do
have a significant um higher Acuity of
residents than the DD homes which are
the ones that we hoping to be Exempted
with similar to the DD homes so there
was a concern about the Acuity of our
residents compared to the residents of a
DD home and also there are some
complications with the current rules
through the Board of Nursing so for us
to implement some of this it would
affect uh Board of Nursing rules which
would affect lure of the staff that work
for us um so if if we are Exempted and
and um I me not be representing this
completely but my understanding is if
you exempt us it does create some
concerns about our staff who are lnas
how does that affect their lure because
when you hold that license you're are
held to those rules so unless we also
modify Board of Nursing rules um they
cannot work outside of the scope of
their practice so there are still
concerns about them being in violation
of their lure because they are still
required to follow Board of Nursing
rules so that's where you get some
complication in the overlap between um
current Board of Nursing rules which
govern their lure as opposed to just uh
trying to exempt us we still have staff
that have to follow their licensure
requirements does that help address that
concern follow up representative Weber
well here's my
problem the bill as it was
drafted as opposed to as you have been
discussing it going
forward um and I understand all of the
reasons you're wound up in the Board of
Nursing rules but the bill is drafted is
working off of an what appears to me to
be an existing statute that talks about
the administration of medications by any
person employed or under contract to
provide Direct Care to pay clients
receiving communitybased
services and um so presumably this is
already happening in the
community and if so um either they have
gotten around you know it's it is I was
assuming as I read it that we were
talking about people who were not lnas
um
and
so yes so correct so the original bill
was drafted to allow unlicensed staff to
take a separate training
program in a nutshell somewhat
equivalent to the current m&a um
certification course um but having said
that how does that affect our LNA staff
who are a large percentage of our staff
they still would be unable to administer
medication so if it were to go for it as
currently drafted it would allow
unlicensed staff to potentially obtain
that additional training but it does not
solve the problem that a majority of our
staff are lnas and they would still be
unable to administer medication
so it would help with some of the
workforce staffing issues and the safety
issues but it didn't resolve it fully
enough for us to feel comfortable that
that was the best path
forward followup so my last followup is
what would be the harm of passing this
bill as it is drafted so we can address
part of the problem and then allow
people to come in with the other
legislation going forward that will
address the issue of the lnas and and
all of those issues of having to wait
two entire years before you take the
medication
training what's the harm of passing it
as it is and then allowing that to come
afterwards no I would say that that
would be an acceptable approach as
well and then I do think there would be
definitely interest in pursuing further
so that we're addressing it for all of
the staff that it would apply to but I
agree with what you're saying I hear
what you're saying and and we're not
opposed to that I think we were looking
for a more comprehensive solution all at
once but I understand that yes it would
help with some of the the current
staffing needs and then we could come
back and address it
further representative
Merchant uh is follow up to
my volunteerism instead of a sub
committee is it possible to have an ad
hoc committee therefore we could have
people meet via Zoom um if there's
interested parties no we cannot do that
committee rules don't allow it even as
the a hoc committee it's an official
no
sorry representative
kushman thank you Mr chairman um thank
you for being here and um I appreciate
this legislation very much um as a nurse
and uh I occasionally work in assisted
um Assisted Living fac facilities so I
understand this need um but as the as
I'm reading this bill here I don't see
that it as it's written now I see that
it it exempts even lnas who otherwise
under the um nurse Practice Act are
required to work for two years and then
um you know get that medication
administration CER certification this
exempts any person employed or under
contract um who's caring who's giving
Direct Care to clients in these
facilities as written now so then if we
made that change then um if there was
any conflict with the rules that are in
place that would trigger the department
to have to go back and bring the rules
into compliance with the law um so as I
see it now it looks like this bill does
exactly what you want it to do do you do
you see what I'm seeing I understand
what you're saying there definitely
would be some conflicts for the
currently licensed staff but I
understand what you're saying if it did
require it then to subsequently require
those rules to be reviewed um that would
be
agreeable other
questions seeing none thank you okay
schar
Mr chair members of the committee thank
you for the opportunity to address you
on House Bill
1585 uh my name is g k I live in
Peterboro uh I am an Advisory Board
member of uh New Hampshire Arch I'm an
Advisory Board member because um I'm
retired so I can no longer be a full
member of the board um for 37 years my
wife and I ran Friendship Manor which
was a 22-bed residential care SL
assisted living home in new whip in newp
switch uh we were forced to close
Friendship Manor in May of
2022 um because we could not hire enough
staff to keep operating uh so this this
question at least
tangentially uh was an issue in our
closing clo closure excuse me um my role
with New Hampshire Arch over the years
and i' I've been a member of New
Hampshire Arch um for more than 30 years
um and I've been on the board for most
of the last 30 years um but I've always
been involved with legislation I was
either the vice president for
legislation or chair of the legislation
committee um and my first um interface
with the legislature with the house was
in
1994 um there was a v a study committee
1994 uh to determine what the rates
should be the reimburse rate should be
for um Residential Care the reason there
was a need for a committee was because
the rates have been frozen for seven
years and people were going out of
business um but one of the things that
committee did was to look into all of
the factors that were affecting
residential care and what the cost
factors were and one of the big areas of
concern was medication
administration um and at that time that
subcommittee looked into the system
which is used in the DD and the Mental
Health Community residents
and said this sounds like a good thing
um but the committee decided that its
principle and priority was rates so they
met a recommendation with regard to
rates in the in the in the form of a
bill um but said we'll take up the
medication administration in the future
um there was an effort over the next
couple of years to do something about
medication
administration
um there was a proposal for a pilot
program but basically those efforts
failed uh due to opposition from the
Board of Nursing and the New Hampshire
Nurses Association so that was not the
time but I think we're long past time
there was a story that I I told in that
study committee years ago uh I had a
resident whose name was Don Don had
Parkinson's disease and had a notable
Tremor in both hands he also had
glaucoma and had to take eye drops daily
and legally we couldn't help him in any
significant way with his eye drops okay
we were told that well you can do it
hand over hand in other words he can
hold the bottle you can put your hand
over his and together you can squeeze
the bottle but he has to be the
Principal squeezer of the bottle and we
would have triy that and they drop with
him in the hit him in the nose roll down
his nose and fall onto the floor
so there's been a problem for a long
time um and I agree with representative
Weber it doesn't seem like it should be
that complicated but I think it's
perhaps
time the time is right because now there
is a consensus among all the
stakeholders that something needs to be
done so I just urge us after 30 years to
get this
done thank you thank you representative
Weber so is getting it done in your
opinion passing the bill as it is or is
getting it done changing the bill into a
study
committee I don't like the idea of study
committee because I'd like it to be done
more quickly than that um so
representative Merchant's suggestion
that uh um a subcommittee could be
formed might be helpful one of the
issues and I'm I'm not as conversing
with this topic as Sarah is but one of
the issues with just passing the bill as
it is uh comes around hm
1201 which are the rules that apply to
community residences and the question is
should those rules apply to Res
Residential Care Homes are they wholly
appropriate to Residential Care Homes or
could something else perhaps less
restrictive be done that's just one
question that would come to mind so I
think a little bit of
study around that would be helpful but
again I don't want to postpone things as
long
as as long as the calendar would
indicate if we went with a study
committee other
questions seeing no other questions
you also signed up to speak is Doran
shley from the Department of Health and
Human
Services you don't indicate an amount of
time how much time do you think you're
looking for
here three minutes
okay okay I always forget there we go
now it's on um good afternoon um
committee members I am Dorian shakley I
am the manager of the Bureau of
Licensing and certification at the
Department of Health and Human Services
uh I was not intending on speaking today
um and I hope that I will be very brief
I wanted to clarify some items that have
come up a few times um we the department
um the Bure or I'm sorry part of the
Bureau of Licensing and certification is
our adult licensing unit Kelly Keefe is
the unit chief of that unit has been
actively involved with Sarah and her
colleagues in terms of changing the
rules and we have worked very closely
with the sponsors on this bill we have
also met regularly with um the EMB
budsman office who's here we've met with
the oplc the Board of Nursing has been
invited to these sessions um we all
agree that this is a very important
topic and things need to happen however
the way the bill is written now doesn't
completely solve the issue and as we
were going oh um as we were going
through a lot of the meetings uh
representative Maguire is also present
and one of her AIDS was going to do some
research to determine the history on why
um the community-based services are
exempt from and um representative wber
you've brought this up a few times and I
just want to clarify the difference
there's a very distinct difference
between community- Based Services and
our licensed residential facilities uh
Community Based Services are certified
through um a community residence unit
that I also oversee and there are no
more than four individuals living in a
home I could be one of those providers
you could be one of those providers um
so then when you get into a residential
setting you have um usually more than 16
individuals there are also as we were
progressing through this conversation
there's layers and layers there's life
safety there's fire code um so there's
all it it involves many different
agencies and many different stakeholders
so we thought that the the important
thing to do was to pause and to figure
out what is the best way to all gather
together to make sure that we come up
with a bill that covers all of it and
keeps the people and the residents that
are in these facilities safe not all
facilities are going to do as Sarah has
been well at explaining so we need to be
very careful that the training that
these individuals are going to have
meets a certain threshold so um again we
all agree that something needs to happen
but going to study whatever that is
called commission committee I've heard a
lot of language and I'm sorry I'm not as
familiar with that as I should
be any representative Shapiro thank you
Mr chairman um I heard you say that um
you don't think that this language
solves the problem um
um and it's and and I also heard you say
that we all have to get together to
solve this problem but it seems like
you're in a unique position um and I
wonder if you could come up with
language to solve the problem so um I
would love to be part of the committee
that um representative Merchant is going
to oversee um so and again we have um we
have a lot of interest already within
the State Department of Health and Human
Services so I know we are all committed
to doing this so and I agree with Gary I
mean the sooner the better um but it
needs to be thoughtful and intentional
and and solve all of the issues and make
sure that we've taken everything into
consideration because at the end of the
day we want all of our residents to be
safe follow up followup thank you um my
my experience working currently on a few
other bills that we're trying to get
agreement among people is that um even
where there's not that much disagreement
um is it's difficult and sometimes if
there's
um if there's a starting point which you
may be uniquely positioned to um have um
um I I don't know what my question is
except that um I I guess my question is
are you confident that the this group of
people meeting together for
a short amount of time could come up
with the solution absolutely okay thank
you representative
Weber
so in generating a
solution
um would
you care to comment on my bewilderment
here because when this was when this
issue came to me and I'm one of the
sponsors it was from my County Nursing
Home
administrator who was very concerned
about staffing issues as everybody else
is and medication administration in the
context of our County nursing home and
now as far as I can tell the discussion
doesn't include County nursing homes at
all
and while I wonder how we got from to
hear
um I'm still left with that question
that I've asked everybody else if this
is done in a facility that has more
supervision rather than less supervision
because the initial concept had to do
with County nursing
homes would that be a problem for the
department so I'm un aware of any County
nursing home that has had this challenge
or has brought this to so I'm happy to
have any conversations with that
administrator or perhaps that
administrator or other representatives
from the County nursing homes should be
part of this study uh or commission
committee whatever we're calling it I'm
not sure I understand more supervision
um when you have a community residence
that has three maybe four residents that
are DD or developmentally disabled or AC
acquired brain disorder I'm sorry I'm
forgetting there's another side of the
room here
um those folks have lower Acuity needs
than in general than um an assisted
living facility and I think Sarah
articulated that very well there's
different levels two different levels of
an assisted living and then there's the
nursing homes which are which comprise
the bulk of our residential settings a
community residents doesn't fall under
that same definition they are carved out
as as separate and distinct so they also
have Staffing but often times in a
community resident the Staffing is one
to one so the Staffing ratio in a
community residence is often much higher
than that in a assisted living facility
so we're talking about apples and
oranges um and I know that's it's really
it's really complex and for that I'm
sorry um but and that's why I think to
representative Shapiro's question um I
think the folks that have already been
discussing this and we're so thankful to
the sponsor and and and the folks that
have brought this forward that they have
engaged with us early on we've been
talking about this for months and
meeting on it very carefully you said
and I my answer was absolutely you said
in a short period of time I should have
asked for you to Define
that
representative
Shapero thank you Mr chairman I'm I'm
not sure it increases my confidence to
know that you've been working on it for
months um this is a question for the
chair we've talked about varieties of
way to to study this or come to some
kind of agreement would one way be for
just the stakeholders involved and DHHS
to continue working on a solution with
maybe one member of our committee
um sitting in with them would that be
not an official committee and could that
happen by zoom and could that be a more
informal process since we have a number
of weeks before we have to exact this
bill um that's kind of a unique approach
um representative Weber uh do you know
of that having been done
or okay well as as let me first say as
as the short answer uh um we need to
report this out if we're going to report
it out and not have an interim study or
a study committee if we're going to have
an actual bill our last day to report
that is March 21st so that's a drop dead
deadline and you could certainly pursue
both options you know on the one hand
let's see if we can come to a resolution
and on the other hand let's have a a
study committee ready to go if we can't
but it has to get done by March 21st
that's item number one item number two
is that as long as it is not an official
committee or a subcommittee of this
house everybody in the state of New
Hampshire has a right to consult with
anybody else in the state of New
Hampshire as they please um and so any
group that wants to get together is is
welcome to do so and they're welcome to
invite anybody they want to invite
through whatever means they wish for
whatever means as long as we're not
violating the right to no law which
would be mean a majority of this
committee which isn't a um a political
caucus so um you you can certainly have
meetings with okay less than a majority
of this committee plus anybody else who
participate um but we need for
legislative purposes to have some kind
of action on the bill by March 21st
because that's the deadline for our um
committee to report and that's over a
month and a half okay and so that's very
helpful thank you representative wber so
if I
understand the the sponsor and and we've
been meeting for months but not like
weekly or daily um not that we would
meet daily but um we could in fact
increase the frequency of our meetings I
think and then if we were to come up
with with language that makes sense even
shortterm and then longterm something
else as long as we as long as the
sponsor has something to you by the
March 21st date then we'd want it before
that we'd like it before that because
yes bear bear in mind that we also if I
may Mr chair have to get it through OS
which is legislative drafting we can't
we're not allowed as a committee to vote
on something that looks like this we
have to take it to legislative services
and get them to draft and they are
serving 424 of us it would be well was
going to be an kind of an informal
effort it could be as simple as just
deferring any executive committee
executive session action until March
yeah we could do that certainly so um I
clearly can't speak for the sponsor or
all the stakeholders but I I thank you
for this information I've never in all
the years I've been doing this had this
type of situation R so I appreciate the
flexibility and the opportunity to
continue working together to see if we
can come up with a combined solution
even if that's shortterm and long
term representative Merchant thank you
Mr chair
also I don't think we have to get it
exactly correct um this is going to go
to the other chamber so if we're close
we can then continue the process or the
chamber on the other side could continue
the process to find tuna to make it
exactly what people want so wanted to
let people know that we don't we do have
more than March 21st for the house but
we still have time on the other side of
the wall perfect thank
you anyone else representative Kofa
might I suggest that we U specify when
when we would need it because right now
we know that it's sometime before March
21st but if we allow time for redrafting
and for additional hearing discussion
and exact um what what date would we
like for there to be a proposal of some
hand yeah the week of the 5th or the
week of the 12th of
March and again we usually been doing
this on
Wednesdays so what the 7th or the well
14th is really pushing it those those
are the wedes sorry those are the
Tuesdays the 6th or the 13th of March
would be a good
date six let's aim for the sixth on all
of these six
okay okay so March six sharpens the mind
to have a deadline have a work
session so just to be clear we're we're
proposing that anybody who wants to
bring a proposed amendment would have
the parameters for that proposed
amendment by the six so that it could
then be sent to OS and we could discuss
sit here you know have a hearing in
exact session on the
13th the sixth right didn't we say the
sixth yeah so the thought would be
there's probably going to be several
bills some that we have subcommittees
some that we just informally have people
working on and it would be good to
ideally shoot proba for the sixth if we
can for any of these so we can discuss
them and see if there's further work
that for hearing an exact for for a work
session potentially yeah I think we
would have to notice them for a work
session on the sixth and that gives us
the ability to discuss among ourselves
which direction we're going in as a
committee okay and and I guess I'm
suggesting that we back it out a couple
of days for OLS to to draft something so
that we have
something clear to look at so I I'm just
I I guess if I if I walk it backwards
I'm looking at Friday the 1 of March as
a well Poss representative
Weber I thought that the point of the
sixth was you could discuss it on the
6th and then send anything to O l s
which would give us drafts for the 13th
which would keep us well within our
within our time frames exact and give
you the maximum amount of time to get
get it done and that's why I was
suggesting that we notice the sixth as a
work session so we can take it up and
and either put it down or or just send
week representative mlan so that mean
DHHS and Arch they go off they meet and
you also signed up to speak on this bill
buckton
good afternoon my name is Susan buckon
I'm the state Long-Term Care edsman
thank you for allowing me to speak I um
as Dorene said was not prepared to to
speak today but um it sounds like given
this last comment I would agree with
that plan um as Dorene had had talked
about I also served on some of the
meetings and I believe at the end of the
time which you know was just a couple of
weeks ago we really had identified there
were a couple of things in this bill
that created some problems one of them
was the reference to RSA 151 which
includes nursing homes and there would
be conflict created if this bill were to
pass as written um with the regulations
that are that oversee that are oversee
the nursing homes um and so we need to
really be clear about which level of
care we're talking about I think the
other concern is we really need to fold
in the Board of Nursing and not create a
whole separate system of individuals
that are providing service in long-term
care and before um one of the other
committees in the house is the the um
question of
certification versus um registration of
nursing assistance um and I think there
is a uh a plan to continue to work work
on that and I think these two bills do
dovetail because we're now talking about
creating a whole separate subset of
individuals that are going to work in
long-term
care and um within the Residential Care
setting and I I'm sorry I missed um some
of the early test earlier testimony and
I know that um Sarah probably spoke to
the difference between the 804 and the
805 facility but even within those fac
facilities there's a tremendous amount
of variation between the types of
service and the types of individuals and
the complexity of their medical
conditions that live within those
buildings and I just want to make sure
that we are really thoughtful that we're
creating a set of laws that takes into
account all the different um types of
settings in which this
would this would cover and that we're
we're really thoughtful that we're not
creating a situation which is unsafe for
the individuals that live in those
buildings I'm happy to answer any
questions or
clarify okay representative Lon U thank
you Mr chairman and thank you for coming
up to offer this Insight would those
rules I think it's both okay um then as
a followup if it's possible to get
information to us what what laws um and
which specific St sections of the
statute would be in conflict that would
help us with the work okay thank you
other
questions seeing none thank you thank
you okay I have no one else signed up to
speak on um HB
1585 uh on the blue sheet in the back uh
two people did sign up in favor um and
when person signed up just to provide
information and what was the three and
two online it was three in favor and two
opposed
okay so with no other no one else signed
up I'm going to close the public hearing
on HB
1585 and open the public hearing on HB
1568 uh the prime sponsor uh
representative uh sellers I believe is
unable to be here but representative Tim
MCU is here on his behalf welcome
representative
you thank you Mr chairman good
afternoon I think it's been 22 years
since I've been in front of the HHS
committee and the last time was for an
ambulance bill also some of you might
remember uh EMS was in 151b a long time
ago until we put it in 153a and I think
that's the last time I was here believe
it or not so this
bill excuse me this bill is meant to
help our ambulance providers recoup
their costs when they go to a call and
provide treatment and use resources and
don't have any way to submit for payment
unless they transport the patient so the
best example I can give you and the most
common one and I suspect you might even
hear it again from those behind us is um
in my 33 years as a
paramedic um the typical
situation is a diabetic an unconscious
unresponsive hypoglycemic diabetic um
it's marginally routine for that disease
state for in some cases that you find a
diabetic who's just for some reason
their sugars gotten out of whack they
didn't eat they exercise too much
whatever it is and their loved ones or
even they call uh and you check their
sugar start an IV provide some uh
intervenous glucose oxygen and uh ECG
which are part of the standard of care
for that
workup and they wake up and they're fine
they're good as new probably everybody
here knows somebody like that and the
last thing they really want to do is be
loaded into the back of the ambulance
and taken to the ER the last thing the
healthc care system wants to do is pay
for those two things uh especially the
second part which is the Ed visit which
will which will result in typically labs
and other sorts of things um so other
thirdparty payers do compensate for this
and you can imagine why they might
because they also would like to avoid
that expensive VR visit um so this bill
was a request of a constituent of the
Prime sponsor uh representative Sellers
and I can I can tell you that it's a
great idea it's a simple simple fix I
have just learned today that uh our
former division Chief or bureau chief I
forget her exact maybe it was division
director Senator Apprentice she was a
chief of VMS as many of you know uh has
another bill Senate Bill 409 which
probably should be aligned with this
bill there's some language in that bill
that um qualify how the services were
accessed like through the 911 system
it's a few good pieces of that bill so
probably both of these should go
together and I think um there's probably
10 or 12 or 14 Senators co-sponsoring
that other bill so it might be nice if
these two age agreed um when we when we
get it so I'm sorry I literally just
learned of it a short time ago so I
don't have a proposed amendment for the
committee I would I would have done that
work for you and I'm happy to do that
work for you um but in summary it's you
know hundreds of dollars thousands of
dollars at the ER that could be easily
saved and it's much better for the
patient if they are able to just stay
home uh and the providers are
functioning at their level of Lure by
allowing that to happen by
uh allowing them to sign a refusal of
transport and I can talk to the fiscal
note too uh which actually just came out
today let me talk to the fiscal note
real quick because maybe that'll answer
some other questions um the fiscal note
came out today and talks about um
significant additional expenditure in
ambulance reimbursement that's probably
likely uh but it would be more than
offset by the savings uh of what is
often the current practice which is put
the patient in the ambulance before
before you do the workup now they're
still unconscious or semiconscious and
they you've got their implied consent to
transport them and therefore you can
generate a bill right and and that is
specifically the message that was told
to us and I say us myself and my
colleagues working for a private
Ambulance Service once the hospitals
stopped replacing our consumables our IV
setups and our drugs and all that for
free and it started coming out of the
private ambulance's pocket guess what
happened we transported every patient
right because that's ailable run so we
were for essentially forced to do that
to get some reimbursement uh and those
workups would happen in the back of the
ambulance instead of in the patient's
living room so ask yourself which is
better I think we all know the answer so
hopefully that if you look at the fiscal
note it's it doesn't uh account for the
offset the savings offset for ambulance
or ER visits that typically would
accompany uh this type of patient
representative Seth King are you all set
representative Weber
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question so essentially all
we're doing is we are looking at
Shifting the costs which are now borne
by I'm not I don't I'm not aware with
the private ambulances but I certainly
am aware about the town ambulances the
costs are currently shouldered by the
town entirely because it's the ambulance
service and what this would do would be
to Avail ourselves of federal
remuneration at least to some degree so
that would
offset both the charges on the town and
the resultant property taxes is that
right yeah that is my understanding and
so every town does it a little bit
differently some towns don't bill at all
uh for ambulance services to their their
Town's people you know it's sort of part
of their services they provide uh in
their taxes um some Bill only if the
patient has Insurance some other some
some some paay could be Medicare
Medicaid or or private insurance um so
some don't build at all some build only
with insurance um but definitely this
would help those towns that are
otherwise just bearing the cost of those
non-transport treatment sessions and
it's not just for diabetics there's
other other other possibilities
too so yeah I believe correct thank you
for the question other questions
representative kushman thank you Mr
chairman and thank you for bringing this
bill and taking my question um I am
wondering about and I know we've touched
on it a little bit do you have any idea
what the cost increase is going to be to
towns and companies to have Personnel
qualified to submit the insurance
claims um um repr of kushman that's a
great question question and the answer
is no I don't really know um but I do
know that virtually every town
bills in some fashion they already
they're already set up to submit an
invoice when there's a payment
Source not too many towns don't bill at
all like just ignore that part you know
they file the run sheet and then just
don't send anybody a bill um so I
suppose that the towns could choose to
continue to not submit a
bill I mean that's that's their current
practice it's already borne by their
their tax base and they might choose to
not take advantage of this source of
reimbursement followup thank you um in
my town we will send a bill
um but it's just an invoice and then
it's the responsibility of the person if
they have insurance to then send that to
their insurance um but we also have um a
policy that if the the need for services
was a result of um some negligence or
the person was under the influence um
and they denied transport that we send
them a bill for that as well um is there
anything in here to kind of set that
kind of situation
aside um and exempt it from this
coverage no uh not in this bill in 49 it
might be and I'm not sure I'd have to
pull up the text of 409 it's a bit it's
a bit longer but I I don't think there
isn't either and I I think the uh
Department's attorney is behind me and
he can probably answer that question
he's much more familiar with that
particular
Bill other questions representative
Weber so this is a question of the chair
in terms of procedure given that there
is another bill in the Senate would it
not be simpler for us to pass the
legislation that we think we ought to
pass send it to the Senate and then let
the Senate change our legislation into
their legislation and then it all comes
out in the wash at the end rather than
uh trying to justify them back and forth
certainly it's a worthy objective I'm
not sure how the the sense of the
committee is but would make sense yeah
yeah I just was trying to make it
simpler on us sure
sure
yeah other
questions representative Merchant did
you have your hand up a moment
ago more of inquiry um thank you Mr
chair and thank you for taking the
question in the community that I reside
there's a frequent number of um 911
responses and a lot of it is sort of
what I call false
responses and what triggers it is many
of the elderly
have um devices and actually have things
on your Apple watch now if you fall and
so forth and it triggers a response but
there really is no matter medical
emergency to it so how do we break that
apart from somebody who's truly like a
diabetic and needs a medical response
but it wasn't something triggered by
technology triggered by something that
was sort of what I call a false alarm
yeah great great question thank you
representative Merchant for that uh and
it's it's a valid point we should bring
that up because there are a lot of those
life call responses my own parents and
others have been through that uh that
generally doesn't generate treatment or
a
billable case a billable uh patient care
record so you know just a lift assist
back in you know off the floor to the
couch and they're fine there's no workup
there there's no you know nobody
starting an IV or giving oxygen or
anything like that um so that that
typically wouldn't generate a bill on
its own it's usually just a public
service thank you other
also signed up to speak a Rob Barry and
David shney from the Department of
Services good afternoon uh Mr chair
members of the committee my name is
robberry I'm general counsel to the
division of Medicaid for the New
Hampshire Department of Health need
services and with me is good afternoon
uh David chy Deputy Medicaid
director uh so we uh are supportive of
uh this bill um we um we've provided
similar testimony at s sp49 which was
mentioned earlier uh we were going to
suggest that the two bills do align as
sp sp 409 does have some parameters in
there that we think is helpful for uh uh
to for the Department in terms of
determining uh how a service would be
reimbursable uh also uh there was some
contingency language in s409 I believe
that was just added this morning through
an executive session uh that would make
the bill contingent upon approval from
CMS um so other than that uh I'm happy
to take any questions you may have thank
you
representative Shapiro could you check
the blue sheet for me on this and see if
there's anyone on there or perhaps bring
it
up and representative Val on who signed
up
online online there were 36 in support
neutral people definitely like the
online process better one person signed
sheet does anyone else wish to testify
in hb1
1568 seeing no one I'm going to close
the public hearing on hb1 1568 and open
the public hearing on
hb1010 and recognize the prime sponsor
kushman
her
be able
it good afternoon representative kosman
good afternoon thank you Mr chairman
thank you members of the committee I am
before you today uh well for the record
my name is uh Leah kushman I represent
hb1010 relative to expanding maternity
options in mid rerey access
um so I'll start with just a little bit
of background on what Midwifery is um
the practice of Midwifery under uh the
statute that we have that governs it
control of our handouts but we have
these have stopped there's another one
here are there more of
these div I didn't divide them no okay
but I don't have any and the clerk
doesn't have any oh did they stop at my
seat okay I didn't get the second
one I've oh you that one I apologize I
but I don't have that one I think that
one
everyone all set now okay thank you
sorry no worries
continue um
so under their scope of care this this
statute it's um the administrative rules
that govern Midwifery are created by a
Midwifery Council um which is made up of
three uh New Hampshire midwives and an
OBGYN and a physician I believe um and
it acts just like the Board of Nursing
or the other boards where they they vote
on their rules um and so under their
scope of practice in the rules are under
mid 100 to
500 uh they provide counseling and
education holistic care early
recognition and prevention of potential
health problems detection of abnormal
conditions of the mother fetus and
newborn procurement of medical
assistance if necessary and execution of
emergency measures in the absence of
medical help if NE if necessary and
lactation
assistance um they're trained and
licensed to provide breast exams pelvic
exams Vin a puncture and IV fluid
administration hematocrit and hemoglobin
specimen collection capillary blood
collection Pap testing cultures Ur
analysis um oxygen Administration
otomies repair of tears and
lacerations um and injections and
neonatal
resuscitation so I just giving you a
global kind of overview of what midwives
are now there are certified nurse
midwives who are advanced practice
registered nurses um as far as I can
tell these rules do not cover them
there's also Physicians assistants who
can help with birth and they may have
some certifications in that area as
well um and then we have your OBGYN
which is a different scope of practice
so the council handles the
certifications complaints regarding
licenses scope practice continuing
education and the like um there are a
small number of midwives in New
Hampshire but is a growing industry um
as demand
increases um so there are some things
that the rule that the rules um in mid
500 specifically require um that a
Midwifery terminate um the care
relationship with the mom for uh it's
there to to protect the mom's um safety
and and a lot of it is um you know based
on a study study well I'll get to that
sorry um it seems like there's a
difficult process to have an amendment
made to those rules you can petition a
rule change in writing and satisfy
written explanations of um what I think
it call what what um what it calls for
and then they send you a decision and an
explanation but I don't think that the
majority of patients um mothers who are
pregnant know how to go about asking for
these changes and I happen to be plugged
into um communities where a lot of these
moms who um would rather have a home
birth are and I hear from them all the
time um their complaints about their
access to Midwifery care um so that's
why I brought this bill forward as a
representative I'm bringing on behalf of
the
people um Midwifery is not a novel
practice and uh the per purpose
statement of RSA 326d says um it it
explains clearly that women are going to
choose home birth and they're at
increasing rates and if they're going to
we should allow them to have help
available many women right now are
precluded from Midwifery care for the
reasons listed in the bill um which I
will expound on um and they would rather
give birth beside a river alone than go
to a hospital and receive Care at a
hospital and so if we're concerned about
safe of women and infants in home birth
um that's something that's a question
that we need to ask ourselves um is it
safer to deliver at home with a midwife
in a potentially higher risk higher risk
situation or is it safer to birth
alone um so the conditions that are
bill um the first one is multiples I'll
get to that later um I got questions
about you know the the statistics on the
risks so we'll talk about vaginal births
after
cesarians right now you can have a
vbac um it's called colloquial
colloquially a v-back um you can have
one have midwe recare after you've had
one but you can't have midwar for your
care if you've had two so this build
just brings it up to you can have one
after two uh the Northern New England
paranal quality improvement network uh
which provides a
document and guidelines for health
workers um and and that document is used
to provide informed consent that's
required
by uh rules for midwives to do
vacks they have in their guidelines
that the risk for uterine rupture is
approximately. 3 to
7% in a person who has
had um one v-back and then the risk for
a uterine rupture is likely greater than
7% for two prior vacks so there is a
risk there now how you would determine
that risk versus how someone else would
would
um would look at it can be
different um but essentially there are
other things that come into play when
we're talking about risk you know you
could have a person who is completely
healthy and has had um one cesarian
section and has no other risk
factors or you could have someone who
has had um has had two and no other risk
factors or you could have someone who's
never had a cesarian section but has a
lot of other RIS risk factor so it's
like a matrix that you need to consider
um and that is something I think that
Midwife should be able to
consider um I think that we talk a lot
about not regulating the practice of
medicine um not you know not legislating
seeing I'm seeing in these rules that
there's no other practice that's more
regulated than Midwifery I mean I would
be terrified to work as a midwife in New
Hampshire because it's the rules are so
cumbersome I mean it's almost impossible
with the standards of practice for you
to I mean the way I see them to follow
them completely um and there's nothing
in there about you know patients being
able to refuse certain things either so
it assumes that patients will just do
whatever you say um so that that's where
the liability comes in but so midwives
are are trained in birth work these are
CPM certified professional midwives they
go to school uh a a accredited school
then they have to have a preceptorship
they get experience they take courses on
laceration
repair and
many receive instruction and can even go
and be certified on breach delivery
malpresentation of the fetus that's what
the next
um the next
um disqualifier for Midwifery care is
malpresentation so we know that is
breach right um I did pass out a couple
of handouts one is an article from
2019 um it's in the Journal of midify
today it's a literature review um if you
look on page
two um it's mentioning the rcog which is
Canada's version of the American college
for Obstetrics and
Gynecology um and talking about how they
updated their breach guidelines in 2017
and estimated the risk of paranal
mortality during a planned vaginal
breach birth at around 1 out of 500
compared to one out of a th000 for
Planned birth and one out of 2,000
for a planned cesarian
section uh this number aligns with many
large National Registries and meta
analyses however in France and Belgium
which have retained a strong tradition
of vaginal breach birth and continue to
teach breach in residency programs large
highquality perspective Studies have
found no differences in neonatal
outcomes and there's a lot of comparison
of many studies in this article too so I
encourage you to read the whole thing
um so it used to be taught
routinely uh it's something that is
taught routinely
elsewhere now it's no longer really
taught there was a study that came out I
think it was 2003 it's called the breach
um trial and it pretty much put a death
Nowell in the idea of any planned
vaginal breach births and since then uh
most um most hospitals will not even
permit a woman to attempt a vaginal
delivery with a breach baby um mostly I
think because nobody's trained in that
delivery um and also hospitals tend to
operate on a risk
reduction um
Paradigm so it used to be taught
routinely we have fewer birth workers
who who do this but there seems to be a
higher percentage of birth workers who
are certified in you know repositioning
or delivering breach babies uh among
midwives so in New Hampshire the the
hospitals won't attempt this the policy
is C-section is the only option so
what's a mom to do she's 37 weeks she's
been seeing a midwife the whole time her
baby still
breach and now she's really concerned
that she's going to have to just go to
the hospital and have a
C-section ACOG and JC both give the
green light for vaginal breach births to
be attempted in hospitals but their
recommendations are silent on vaginal
breach birth and home
setting uh advances in labor and Risk
Management International uh have
selection criteria for Planned vaginal
breach deliveries their key messages are
the decision is to perform the decision
to
perform um involves providing informed
choice to the woman regarding risks
benefits and healthc care provider
competencies when a woman presents with
a breach baby a vaginal delivery should
be encouraged if she meets the criteria
and health providers should develop and
maintain their skills in vaginal breach
delivery The Who guide that you have in
front of you also has a a guide for
breach
birth um which I passed out um multiples
it's more of the same yes there there is
an increased risk of complication but
healthy multiple deliveries do occur in
homes across the United States all the
time um in other states midwives deliver
Twins and it's not precluded in their
scope of
practice um so this is really just about
you know expanding what moms can access
because right now it's either
go have a C-section or give birth alone
in your living room so um I appreciate
any discussion on this and thank you for
the time thank you any
questions representative Seth King thank
you Mr chair thank you for taking
questions um I'm sorry if you already
mentioned this I missed it um it says
here um or the patient having had fewer
than three previous cesarian
sections um again sorry if you already
talked about that but can you just
elaborate that that seems kind of weird
that there would be a rule that would
say if you've had four or more cerian
sections then it's okay for you to be a
midwife but if you've had less than that
it's it's not allowed I don't know I
just don't get it thank you thank you
for the question um so it's to allow up
to two previous cesarian sections right
now you can only have midwe free care if
one no rule shall be adopted requiring
denial of care for the patient having
sections if it's not clear we can make
it clearer no problem I'll set
representative mlan thank you Mr chair
and thank you for taking my question I
do you have any data on uh the
occurrence of Home births where the
services of a midwife have been uh
denied um I don't have statistics on you
know how often that occurs but there's
many different reasons why um a midwife
would decide to transfer care and not
all of which is even covered in the
administrative rules that are governing
them now um but it it happens fairly
often usually not not during the birth
usually some risk factor is identified
prior to even the end of gestation when
the due date is arrived at and so
they'll have to transfer care um even
even being so in the rules there's a lot
about you have to consult with an with a
MD or an specifically an obstetrician or
a CNM certified nurse Midwife um
regarding continuance of care for
certain things that pop
up um which again I think it's I'm not a
fan of those I feel that the Midwife
should make that decision this is what
they do this is where their training
comes from and they are not going to put
a mom in Jeopardy um this isn't new
ground that we're breaking this is an
ancient
traditional um position
but I
digress thank you representative
Merchant thank you Mr chair and also
I always thought of pregnancy being some
of a high risk and it sort of alluded to
that I think in the testimony where if
you have one vaginal
delivery sorry one seat section delivery
and then you have follow with a vaginal
is
7% with complications but if you get to
two it goes to 7% which is concerning do
we have any stats from the office of
profession professional license
insurance certification regards to
concerns and complaints filed against
midwives um and try to understand from
the public what has been voiced with
concerns to the office of professional
license insur certification for
investigations or to
complaints thank you for the question I
think that we could leave that for them
to answer um I don't I don't know about
the complaint rats you had mentioned to
me that you had heard that they were
higher among midwives I don't know why
that is thank you other question
representative U Shapero thank you Mr
chairman
um you you refer to the education that
um needed in order to be certified as a
a certified midwife which is distinct
from a a certified nurse Midwife correct
um could you um refer us to um something
that would elaborate on what that
education is is how long and what kind
of
up so the American College of nurse
midwives certifies nurse midwives and
certified
midwives
um
the national nor American registry of
midwives also
certifies um so you can I I can send you
you know what what they do but it's a
it's a full program um and then you do a
preceptorship with a current Midwife
where you attend a certain number of
deliveries and prenatal appointments and
you um get a certain amount of
experience that is signed off on it's
very extensive it's in mid um 300 I
believe section of the rules if you want
to look at them closely but they're I
mean it's not easy it's a very
challenging process and I've never
worked in Midwifery but I I've
considered pursuing it um and going that
route but I mean it is very cumbersome
of a of an education to consider
pursuing follow follow up yes I I think
that you referred to the complication
rate with um
vaginal birth after
um after a c-section but I don't know if
you did the same with um breach births
but do you know of any information that
might compare the complication rates or
the outcomes
with vaginal breach births done at home
versus done in a hospital
yeah in that the uh article that I sent
you titled the bottom line on breach
um there is a table that talks about um
the role of malpresentation and high
highrisk bursts and neonatal outcomes
and and the author does expound on um
the setting also so like some of these
have different settings and you can see
in the the findings what what the
settings were so there is there is some
data on it although it's very limited um
most studies didn't differentiate that
some studies don't differentiate whether
they're planned um
vaginal breach births or
unplanned um or if the provider was
trained in that or not and it's also
important to mention there are
organizations that specialize in
training these birth workers for um
delivering vaginal breach births um and
of course they're going to have a higher
success rate
um and there's also organizations such
as breach Without Borders who will offer
telea Health um Services during a birth
to assist with that and um and there's
also if we're talking about the risks
and tradeoffs on
page it says 15 but it's the back of the
second page in that packet there's kind
of a comparison between the risks of
cesarian section and the risks of a
planned breach um vaginal
birth and so there are some like for
every it would take I believe it
was 8500 elective
C-sections
um for for breach babies from there were
8,500 elective C-sections for breach
babies from 2001 to
2005 that 8,500 potentially saved 19
babies that's wonderful and then there's
but there's also the cost of four
avoidable maternal deaths for c-section
on the other side nine fetal deaths in
the future due to a uterine scar so if
there's a scar and the placenta attaches
to the scar it can cause um an abruption
later and then the baby loses their
blood supply um 140 life-threatening
maternal complications in future future
PR pregnancies as well so there's a big
picture that needs to be considered not
just the breach um delivery itself but
other risk factors and then the risk of
starian section
alone other
you also signed up to speak is
representative Paige bman from NASA May
minutes thank you Mr chair and thank you
for having me here
committee um some of you met me last
week my name is Paige boschman I am a
registered nurse I have been a nurse
nearly 15 years and most of that time um
I have been working under the Midwifery
model of care I am not a midwife thought
I wanted to be not my deal I don't want
to resuscitate babies um but I an
educator and a lot of that education has
been on educating the public about the
difference between certified nurse
midwives professional midwives Midwifery
care and the and the merits of it which
are very high um I would like to thank
representative kushman for bringing this
up I think that it's a big issue that we
need to be talking about more and I
think that the intent of it is frankly a
it's a refreshing relief um at the same
time I have just a few concerns about it
and I just wanted to really clarify the
difference between a certified nurse
Midwife which a certified nurse Midwife
has a bachelor's degree in nursing and
then goes on to get a master's or higher
level degree as an advanced practice
registered nurse they are very similar
to say a women's nurse practitioner that
is the level of training that they have
uh certified professional midwives also
highly trained just in a different model
and I'm not as familiar with the extent
but you've got the resources for that
it's important to understand the
difference but that we use the word
Midwife for both even though they have
different trainings and practice to be
very clear this bill spe is specific to
the certified professional midwives they
have their own Council by which they are
regulated which is different from CNM
which are regulated and licensed through
the Department of Health and Human
Services I would like to say that
Midwifery care is amazing I've had all
of my babies with midwives I've been
that person that had one cesarian one
v-back and then wanted another vack and
had to transfer from a CPM to the
hospital and have a C-section so I
really understand this situation the
biggest concern that I have after
speaking with CNM and cpms in this state
is that this request didn't come from
the council and there is some
significant concern on their end reason
being uh Midwifery has not been taken
seriously for many many decades and it's
taken the last few decades for them to
gain the reputation that they deserve
midwives provide very very safe
maternity care and births for lowrisk
pregnancies and in fact one of their
greatest skills is recognizing when a
higher risk comes up and then
transferring them their care to obig um
which is which is uh it's it's the way
that we should be working
together in terms of of this some of the
midwives are concerned that the bill as
written could lead to worse outcomes
which could tarnish their hard works for
reputation which they've established in
the state so as a recommendation again I
would recommend that we discuss this but
we turn it back to the council and the
midwives in the state and ask them what
what would they like to be able to do
what makes sense to them what are they
comfortable doing in addition to that
three minutes are up if you could please
start wrapping up I will absolutely add
one more point and the one point was um
in terms of the distance from the
hospital another thing we should talk
about is that due to reimbursement we're
seeing across the country but also in
New Hampshire maternity Wards closing
down in hospital after hospital and if
we do continue with this distance from
hospital rules it makes it less and less
accessible there's lots of problems with
closing maternity units anyway but it
makes this even harder um to adhere to
okay thank Youk you any questions
representative n upam thank you Mr chair
so overall are you against this bill as
it is currently written I'm sorry yes
I'm opposed to the bill as written okay
thank you representa Merchant thank you
Mr chair and thank you for taking the
question in regards to a hospital is it
required the hospital have maternity
care or just that they have to be close
to a hospital so I won't say what I'm
understanding from this is that for most
midwives who will deliver in a
freestanding birth center or attend home
births right now there is there's
usually a recommendation for how far a
that space can be say a person's home
from the nearest maternity unit so that
if a birth becomes high risk and they
need to transfer they're close enough to
get that care in
time
representative South King thank you Mr
chair um and thank you for taking
questions I always love your testimony
because you come from such experience
when you you know you have such
experience in what you're talking about
I I did forget to mention I'm I'm
representative so thank you for those
that didn't
know
um you mentioned
that this isn't coming from the
council
and what I don't understand is so the
council is made up of people who I think
the reason why this bill is being
introduced is because it the council has
historically been overly conservative in
the ru making and this is sort
of taking um taking the risk away from
the council you know because the council
doesn't want to make make a rule that
could backfire and then they get blamed
and we're taking the responsibility for
for overriding their their rules so my
question is is the council only made up
of people that are like really staunchly
Pro Midwife or can it also be filled
with people that generally have a
negative view of Midwifery thank you
there are thank you for your question I
know that there are folks who represent
that Council and so I'll let them speak
to that fully my understanding is it's
made up of cpms to regul and they're in
I'll let them I'll let them answer it
okay other
questions seeing none okay thank you
time also signed up to speak and I hope
I can pronounce this correctly Kathy
Chang from dmouth
hiscock am I
close okay good uh you asked for five
minutes could you keep it closer to 3
please there you go can you guys hear me
now oh yes okay so my name is Kathy
changai and I have been practicing
obgy for 27 years and um I submitted a
written article opposing this house bill
and I cited at Washington Post article
investigative Journal uh that came out
um in a state of Maryland where a couple
has filed a complaint against her
Midwife for poor outcome and I want to
say that in that article they cite that
home birth has twice the amount of
infant mortality than Hospital birth the
second position is that twin deliveries
or multiple gestation pregnancies are
very high risk and um most of these
babies are born pre-term and therefore
when they're born pre-term they already
need Hospital ization and hospital care
in my experience twin pregnancies are
one of the more complicated conditions
not only for the baby but also for the
mom and in my personal experience when
I'm faced with delivering twins it is
something that I take very seriously so
in my background I have done tons of
deliveries both um in the setting of
working in the hospital here in conquer
and I'm now working at the Catholic
Medical Center with certified nurse
midwives we have a very collaborative
relationship with the midwives and I do
support Midwifery care the distinction
is that in this bill you are allowing
deregulation of some of the restrictions
that have been put in place to safeguard
the patient so this bill allows patients
or consumers to decide what is the best
option for them in my opinion I think
the government and the regulatory board
and the licensure committees exist to
protect the public and allow the lay
public to make good decisions by
allowing the public to decide now where
to choose care I think it endangers the
consumer because late midwives working
in a hospital setting certified nurse
Midwifery um with doctors is a very safe
environment but if it is a freestanding
home delivery situation
the multiple birth
pregnancies unstable presentation such
as breach and mother's laboring with
prior uterine scars is a very high-risk
situation and the American College of
OBGYN stand to support deliveries of
Prior cesarian deliveries in a hospital
setting um and the twin deliveries also
should be supported by high-risk Obi
doctors
so my position is that this bill uh
opposes the choice of seeking care to
the lay public and I think the
government and its agencies should exist
to protect the public for making good
choices and good options and by
deregulating or allowing the patients to
have more choice in this particular
situation it is um reckless endangerment
public okay thank you questions
representative
Weber thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question your testimony
brings up something that I hadn't even
thought about
before um when a patient has a
midwife and a complication
arises and the certified
midwife um is is is either required to
or decides that the patient needs to be
transported to a
hospital does the relationship with that
Midwife end at that point or does the
Midwife continue to support the patient
but supported by the more specialized
levels of care I mean it sounded to me
when I was listening earlier that if the
Midwife
isn't um if if the rules prohibit the
Midwife from from doing the delivery
that that care ends and I'm I'm I think
it's very individual some midwives will
come with the patients to the hospital
but I think um that is pretty individual
so in my personal experience um some of
the more difficult outcomes or poor
outcomes were associated with frees
sending mid Vibes doing deliveries at
home that did not end well and as
doctors were're taking uh all comers and
taking care of patients equally but when
you're spaced with a situation that in
my opinion could have been prevented or
proactive care
administered uh it is kind of hard so
there have been a there have been two
cases of infant death when I was at
coner hospital um associated with the
Midwife delivery um gone I guess uh not
home representative Murphy thank you Mr
chairman and thank you for taking my
question um we've heard a lot about the
training of midwives um the nurse
practitioners that care for these
patients for physicians obgyn like
yourself that take care of these
patients if you took this bill and you
substituted the word experienced highly
trained OBGYN with many years of
experience for Midwifery or the Midwife
would it still meet the standard of care
uh taking care of patients pregnant
women in their babies so what you're
saying is doing an an obgy and trained
doctor like me doing a free sending home
birth right with any of these potential
you know scenarios um I would not sign
up for that thank
you representative Shapiro thank you Mr
chairman so when my um oldest daughter
was born um we were going to a
freestanding um birthing center um with
nurse midwives and
um my daughter was breach and um
continued to be breach and so she risked
out of that program and was delivered in
a hospital by the associated
doctor um
and it went fine um so it was a a
vaginal birth and it went fine so what
would my wife and my daughter have
risked by being in
a a setting other than a hospital and
what were the risks even in a hospital
and how would having been in a hospital
mitigated those risks had something I
mean I understand from earlier testimony
that those kinds of births are not done
currently in New Hampshire um but if
they were done what what is the risk
that we're talking about what is what
could go wrong okay so um to answer that
question in a hospital setting you have
a operating room ready for anything
emergent in a Brie birth if um if the
baby is entrapped in the mother's um
womb after the body delivers the head is
ENT trapped that is a very difficult
situation and um and so I think you just
have more resources so that if there are
any unforeseen emergencies that can be
taken care of quickly if you're in a
freestanding uh situation and you're
kind of far from the hospital even if
it's like within 10 or 15 minutes if the
baby's you know not delivered in a
timely manner it could affect the
outcome and I differ with the midwives
position that hospitals do not allow
breach birth it is a shared
decision-making process and we do offer
external calic version so mothers have a
choice with their doctor to decide if
they want to try to turn the baby um
breach deliveries are kind of tricky so
as an OBGYN in my 27 years of experience
I don't do a lot of breach birth because
we're not doing a lot to begin with but
I did have a breach birth vaginally at
CMC with my Midwife at 3 in the morning
and everything went fine so it depends
on the situation so it depends on your
comfort level and how the patient's
doing but the amount of resources that
you have allows you to feel the Comfort
to take something on that's potentially
risky thank you representative
Weber so I think that you've answered my
question with that last answer but I I
was going to ask is it true that there
are no breach births
done vaginally in hospitals and what I'm
hearing you say is no that that does
happen but it's very much an individual
am I right in thinking it's very much an
individual consultation and decision yes
it is really a shared decision between
you as a provider and the patient so if
you're somebody who has uh some anxiety
or you don't have a lot of comfort
because of your training you it is your
obligation to let the patient know what
your comfort zone is and you can call a
backup doctor and sometimes that happens
if the patient is really motivated and
you want the best option for the patient
which you determine is a vaginal attempt
you would try to see what you can do to
allow the vaginal birth to happen so it
happens invariably but again breach
deliveries are not something that we are
trained to do um currently in this model
but it's not discouraged and it's not
something that is
prohibited representative South King
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
questions I think we've established that
uh midwives are highly trained well
educated
individuals um would you agree with that
yes okay follow up follow up um that
being said if under most circumstances a
midwife is presented with one of these
um scenarios do you think that they're
automatically going to just take on the
the task and and do this like at a home
birth or do you think that they're most
likely going to defer to the hospital
anyways and the reason I asked that is
because it sounds like based on the
testimony of the co-sponsor or the
sponsor that um this you're not you're
you're not likely to see a lot of um
midwives performing births under these
scenarios it's more for the patient who
refuses to go to a hospital and this at
least allows somebody to be there who is
trained to help with the birth as
opposed to them having birth all alone
so can you just what are you what are
your thoughts on I really don't know
what um was the impetus for the house
build to be presented um so maybe that's
it that for these patients who truly
choose not to be in a hospital setting
it allows them some whery or some
obstetrical support care yeah I really I
honestly don't know if I can answer that
fairly because I'm a little bit biased
experience other
questions thank you seeing no other
you also signed up to speak is Beth
Council you've asked for two to three
fine U yes I now maybe yeah that's good
okay I'm my name is Beth Gabby I'm a New
Hampshire certified midwife I do home
birth in the state of New Hampshire for
the last 16
years um before then I was in um
Pennsylvania which is not a regulated
State and we did um this is just a
little story we did home breach and twin
deliveries in New Hampshire we don't we
we're regulated and um on behalf of the
Midwifery Council we oppose this bill as
written um that said I invite anybody
who wants to have more discussion about
the bill to come to the next Midwifery
council meeting which is on February
22nd on Thursday at 1:00 over at Eagle
Square um the one so as a council we
opposed this bill we had not heard about
this nobody approached the council to
discuss this um we have very being a
regulated St State we have um um rules
and very clear guidelines when you
consult when you transfer what is
considered a lowrisk birth and um in
those guidelines we consider breach
birth and twin births a higher risk
birth that
said there's room for more discussion
about this bill because the the OBS do
not do breach births in the hospital
they are incredibly rare and when we
when we call ahead if we have a a breach
delivery we need to come to the hospital
we'll have nurses say well better not
come here go to some other Hospital
nobody here is going to do this um we
were trying to find um somebody willing
to do a breach delivery and the and to
my opinion or my experience the obes are
not there are a couple who are
interested in helping us out helping out
the women if they're you know there are
guidelines as what's a higher R risk
breach versus what's a lower risk breach
and um so there is a lot of Education in
the Midwifery sphere that I think is
very useful to OBS and midwives in
general so I guess that's that'll I'll
end my I'll repeat the last thing is
that we oppose this bill the Midwifery
Council however I am interested in more
discussion about opening up choices for
mothers who are a decent candidate who
have a Frank breach to have a safe V
breach
delivery thank you any
questions representative Seth King thank
you Mr chair thank you for taking
questions um I gleaned from previous um
testimony that the Midwife council is
full of individuals who are midwives
themselves and are pro Midwifery is that
correct yeah I'll just tell you who's on
the council we have one obstetrician one
pediatrician three midwives and one
public member okay thank you follow up
follow
up um it was also alluded to by a
previous um individual
that by liberalizing the the rules for
Midwifery that there would be a fear
that something bad would happen and it
would look bad on Midwifery in general
so by opposing uh by opposing this bill
I'm curious if the reason the midwife
council is against it has more to do
with the safety of um the the birthing
process or if
because you're worried that something
bad will happen and then the legislator
will down the line say that's it we're
Banning Midwifery
altogether can you explain thank you
yeah I guess I um I I take a different
approach than when you said liberalizing
if feel liberalizing the the rules to me
it's more like um we could not move
forward with this because we need there
needs to be training you can't just say
I'm a midwife I deliver breach there are
and there are great trainings from
Midwifery in the Midwifery sphere which
is very to my mind very different than
what the OBS are learning is very
different from what the The Midwives are
learning I'd love there to be some cross
talking there but midwives in New
Hampshire they would have to show that
they have had specialized training in
breach it's not it's um that's not a
given and um so there are places to get
that you can go to Tennessee you can go
to the Border you can go to Haiti you
can go all over the place and get
training in from midwives but um we
don't have that right now we also we the
insurance we we can have insurance
coverage because we're regulated um if
we choose to we would like to know would
insurance companies cover us if we did
breach deliveries um would a midwife
have to agree not to do breach delivery
if she wanted to take insurance these
are unanswered questions um Al so it's
just as the rules are currently it's not
in the rules and I think you need to go
through a stepwise progression to
introduce it and cover the safety it is
a public
safety um issue the the council is in
place to keep the public safe
and so we wouldn't willy-nilly say okay
now midwives can do twins and breaches
at home because we haven't stepped up to
those safety measures so rather than
liberalizing which feels like you're
kind of taking away barriers it's more
like stepping it up to make sure that
you have um safety measures in
place representative Murphy and then
representative mlan thank you thank you
for the qu taking the question so is a
followup to representative King's
question in a sense I was curious as to
why the council actually opposed the
bill but are you saying that if the
midwives were specifically trained in
breach
deliveries that as written then with
that Amendment they you would be
supportive of this meaning that you
would have home deliveries for breach
babies prior C-sections
Etc so I I'm taking I would take
separately twins as a separate question
the breach is a separate question and
the cerian separate question as well as
um the minutes away from the hospital
which is also in here I would I would I
I think it's worth more discussion
simply
because if anybody's ever heard of free
birthers free birth um in the we it's
people who who do not use a midwife and
do not use an OB and they and they have
they do their own birth unassisted at
home and there is truth there not very
many but there is a there is there is
enough to talk about women who will
not who will enter a more risky
situation
because they they cannot have their
their vaginal Bach delivery from any
practitioner um that's available
midwives obese um I got off track I
don't remember the question I'm sorry
just follow follow up so so again to
clear I guess we oh open to conversation
I guess the point is is as this bill
stands now we're opposed but I invite
people to come to the council meeting
and discuss it because there are women
who don't have options and I think I
think that's worth discussing sure so
given the prior testimonies by midwives
and Physicians about the increased risks
with this subcategory of patients with
home delivery even if the midwives were
trained in breach deliveries would that
change your opinion or the council's
opinion about a home delivery in a
breach situation I would have to ask the
council my personal opinion if there was
a specific training and numbers of
breaches that you had to show that you
did and you could open up the
possibility of having specialized
midwives specialized and breach who
could do breach or maybe even do it with
the ob in the hospital then yes I I am
in favor of having that conversation in
the hospital well even I mean Frank I
did breaches at home in Pennsylvania
very successfully so um I think there's
a lot of fear around it um and I wasn't
I wasn't trained with fear around
breaches but we also had to triage there
were certain breaches we did not do at
home because they were higher risk
breaches there are lower risk breaches
as well representative mlan and then
representative Merchant thank you uh Mr
chair thank you for taking my question
so um leaving the the issue of the
breaching aside um you you're talking
about limited options for women I mean
I'm not a doctor but I hear on the radio
a lot we're closing down this Maternity
Ward we're closing down that Maternity
Ward so looking specifically at the
distance provision because people's
access especially in the rural areas of
the state is diminishing um what are
your thoughts um with respect to the
distance provision um in the bill um
maybe as it would relate to non highrisk
births would you would you be
comfortable um with that provision in
the case of non- highrisk births or do
you still have reservations around that
so currently the regulations state that
if you are having a home birth there is
no um this is without this is not a
v-back vaginal delivery after cerian
vaginal birth after cerian that's a
v-back we um there is a pro provision
that you need to be within 20 minutes of
the hospital if you don't have a vack
and you're just having a vaginal
delivery there is not a time constraint
on numbers of minutes away from a
hospital so it doesn't like in the North
Country when you're going to be far um
there isn't however with a VB back
there's the 20 minute provision in the
current
rules
follow um and is do do you think that's
that's a valid um so I'm just looking at
because people in rural areas access so
in my in my op this is my personal
opinion because I haven't discussed this
with the council my personal opinion is
um if you are going to have a v-back and
if you're going to have a catastrophic
uterin
rupture then 20 minutes is too long to
be away from a hospital so when we have
um the the risk is low it's low enough
that midwives in the state we we do
vacks and we have women you know full
disclosure they have to understand what
the risk is but in my
opinion it's fine if you are willing if
you know you're a v-back and you're 45
minutes away then um then then that is
totally fine because the risk is so
small if you if you go into that small
percent if you are not in the hospital
you are at risk you know you like 20
minutes doesn't make the difference you
like it's you want to be in the hospital
fast so the so that's my personal
opinion I would not have a problem with
saying if somebody wants a VB back the
Lisk is so low I don't expect a
catastrophic problem and they have the
choice to understand that there is this
percent of a catastrophic problem and
I'm I'm willing to take
that one more followup so just to
clarify so um if you were to amend the
bill just to keep that section in you
would still not be comfortable even with
that section I don't really I don't
really worry about that section okay
yeah thank you representative
Merchant thank you Mr chairman and also
thank you for taking a question earlier
I asked a question to represent of
kushman about the complaints and
investigations uh with midwife in the
state of New Hampshire and I think it
comes under the oplc I was on a
committee during the summer
2022 that issue was raised about the
number
of concerns that were raised by
constituents by people who were
concerned about their Midwife as far as
their
delivery and what I'm trying to get to
is can you share with us as being on the
advisor Council of mid rery um the
number of complaints and concerns and so
forth that come to the council that have
been investigated what the outcomes were
some idea what's out there publicly um
just to clarify the question are you
asking like how how frequent are the
number of complaints about poor practice
in mid rffe out
there I wasn't quite sure exactly what
the comment was at the time um but I
believe there's about 34 35 midwives in
the state of New Hampshire yeah and
there seem to be a disproportional
number of complaints against that subset
of 34 people compared to some of the
other
professions well um I guess there's
probably somebody who can answer this
better than I sitting on the council we
get we receive those complaints we have
very few
complaints is is there a way pleas is
there a way to quantify that with the
numbers
um I I will have to ask for the the
specific numbers like in a in a 5year
period how many complaints we get I'm
correct if I can what I'm trying to get
to is what is the risk currently that
people perceive um rightly or wrongly
that's been voiced with the council to
get a measurement of if we try to look
at that going forward and we build on it
are we looking at concerns complaints
with the mid if you will with the state
where it is today because this will
change things based upon some risk
factors what that may mean to the
constituents going forward okay the
Baseline
um I think the
best if somebody has if somebody's able
to voice that question a little
differently I might be able to
understand it a little better okay may
could you mind if it's just
reworded for me so I'm
sorry I think it would be very helpful
at least for me not speaking for
representative Merchant if we knew the
number of complaints that you had had in
the last 5 years and whatever is
publicly available as to the content of
those complaints and their resolutions
that would be very helpful okay I'm I'm
happy to get that I um thank you off
just to just to another point is that we
get both if things that come to the
counsel are both complaints from the
outside um whoever that may be as well
as if a midwife herself has a
significant morbidity or Mor Al it she
reports that and so we look at all of
those reports coming in the the the
number of Eminem reports versus
complaints it's very I mean we we get I
would say in the last five years I mean
we probably gotten less than five
complaints um but I can get those exact
numbers for
you thank you
questions see no other questions thank
also signed up to speak is Dr Young from
the I believe it's the New Hampshire
Medical
Society afternoon doctor uh you've asked
for five minutes please try to keep it
around
three thank you thank you for allowing
me to testify today I really appreciate
the fact that we have this opport UN in
the state of New
Hampshire my name is Dr o young I'm here
strongly opposed to House Bill
1010 I'm a retired Oban who
practiced uh in conquered for 40 years
and taught uh medical students dmouth
medical students during that entire time
I'm also past president of the New
Hampshire Medical Society and I continue
to serve on the general Council of the
New Hampshire medic medal Society
representing uh all the Obstetricians in
New
Hampshire the most dangerous
practitioners in
medicine are those who do not
know this bill represents to me an
egregious example of this well-known
medical
saying allowing certified leg
midwives to care for high-risk
pregnancies out of the hospital with
very little
training it's important to understand
that a lay
Midwife is
certified with simply a high school
diploma and observation of 25 vaginal
births by another lay Midwife as you've
heard this is very different than a
certified nurse Midwife who has a
bachelor's degree in nursing and three
years of training in a
hospital under the supervision of other
certified nurse midwives and
Obstetricians these nurse midwives
hospitals under the supervision of
Obstetricians because they
I had a year of internship after medical
school and four years of OBG
training I cannot imagine a certified
lay
Midwife wanting to take on the
responsibility of caring for a pregnant
woman in labor who has a baby in a
breach presentation who has multiple
pregnancies who's had previous cerian
sections these are situations that were
the most harrowing situations for
me as a
physician now I understand today the
standard of care in most places is a
cesarian section for breach presentation
I trained and was trained to do breach
vaginal
deliveries but all of us who had that
experience also
experienced occasionally a horrific
complication with that delivery and I
wanted to show you this is from
uh props that I use I'm s props that I
use you can't use props and here oh
really sorry okay well it's the after
coming head to get stuck and it's very
difficult to deliver and I know babies
newborns have suffered death because of
that I can't imagine delivering a breach
baby out of a hospital situation and and
your time is running out please sum up
please wrap up a second Twin can come
down with an arm or a shoulder or a leg
and be impossible to deliver
vaginally twin pregnancy should be
delivered in the hospital and finally
some of us performed emergency surgery
after a ruptured
uterus finding the baby floating in the
abdomen I cannot imagine
being in a home or outside of the
hospital when that happens to my patient
and
baby so just one final short story I
attend South Church most
Sundays uh in conquer and I sit near a
young girl who's 13 years old now names
Angela who suffered prolonged long birth
asfixia when she was delivered by a
certified Lei Midwife she came down with
a tight nucal cord umbilical cord around
her neck and the Midwife did not
resuscitate her she ended
up in conquered Hospital ER 45 minutes
later now she doesn't walk she doesn't
talk she's a beautiful bright
girl but is confined to a wheelchair
all right Sirah thank
you I know the parents
will I know the parents well and they
have long forgiven the certified nurse
Midwife or certified midwife who
delivered her but they cannot forgive
themselves are there any questions for
this please vote itl on this bill so
that we're less likely to have babies
any you taking questions are there any
questions thank you
set also signed up to speak is
representative Emily
minutes good afternoon I am a co-sponsor
on this bill uh representative Emily
Phillips Fremont New Hampshire
Rockingham 7 um this bill was brought
forward because people asked us to um
birth is not a medical event or an
emergency most of the time for a
millennia midwives or late people if you
will have been helping to birth children
I myself um
was was excluded from birthing vaginally
um twice but um this the second time I
ended up with a C-section based on a
mirage of um a myriad sorry of
interventions that were pushed upon me
um in the hospital setting so I ended up
with two C-sections and then I couldn't
find a provider to allow me to try to
deliver my child the way I wanted uh the
only option offered to women in New
Hampshire let me be very clear is
surgical okay for many of these
conditions um so I was seeking a vaginal
birth after uh a second cesarian and no
body in this state this was two and a
half years ago would allow me to deliver
vaginally I played the good game and I
went to the OBGYN I saw a midwife as co-
care and I was just hoping that somebody
was going to support my choice at 37
weeks I asked for it to be considered
individually based on my personal health
in my pregnancy and not based on a label
and I was laughed at and I said I you
were the they told me I was literally
the worst candidate they had for a
vaginal delivery there and so I went
home I gave birth in my bathtub alone
with two douas douas are not medically
trained they are birth support workers
and I'm I'm thankful they were there my
baby had a double nucle cord he was fine
um also that's a variation of normal I
had two prior C-sections I did my
research and
statistically um a woman who's had two
prior C-sections C-sections are very
serious surgical um surgeries and I
appreciate Obstetricians who do them and
they are necessary sometimes okay there
is no way that you can say that major
abdominal surgery is a no risk no big
deal it's major surgery and if I want to
go on to have a fourth child what is the
risk to me for having three major
C-sections when where does my wrist tip
to the point where a uterine rupture
also occurs at the same level when you
get to your fourth C-section okay I want
to live I want to raise the kids I have
but I didn't want did not want to
consent to surgery and nobody would
allow me to try if I had shown up at a
hospital and I'm sure an obset here can
back me up if I had shown up and
declined this surgery I was told I had
to have they would fight me the whole
way while I was trying to labor they
would fight me and I've heard stories of
women being denied pain medicine I've
heard stories of women being treated
poorly and triage and end up delivering
in an ER because they're mad that the
woman will not consent to their Hospital
policy or or rule or whatever that they
must consent to surgery women are free
birthing in New Hampshire it's happening
around me friends with them I you know
that is within their risk to take I
understand their statistics but it is my
risk to take nobody faces more
long-term um liability than the mother
herself what happens in that birth would
have been my fault okay my son is
healthy and fine and everything went
well statistically I knew that would be
the case instead of getting all the
interventions at the hospital I knew
that he would be healthy and thankfully
that's what happened but if something
had happened that would have been on me
please wrap up yes if if the committee
is willing and maybe the Midwife uh
counsel or other people would help would
could we amend this bill to take the
what I believe to be the lowest risk
which is a vaginal birth after two
cesarians and um you know amend it down
to that maybe but there are women who
will choose to give birth alone who
won't has a good outcome as I had
perhaps if we don't allow more access to
midw free care across the state thank
you thank you any
you also signed up to speak and I'll
hopefully I pronounced this correctly Dr
sudhari representing
themselves was I close pretty
close you ask for three minutes
sir thank you for allowing me to speak
my name is Ashish
CH and I'm a board certified OBGYN with
over two decades of experience
delivering lowrisk and higher risk
babies in the state of New Hampshire I'm
the service line leader for Dartmouth
health obgy and services in the southern
half of New Hampshire overseeing the
services of 15 obgy Physicians and 13
clinical nurse midwives who work at
different hospitals three different
Hospital Birthing units in the state
additionally in gerain to this
discussion I have a master's degree in
Health Care delivery science which is
the study of how Healthcare is delivered
factoring in location available
resources population demographics
healthc care
disparities costs and most critically
patient
safety my fellow opponents to this bill
have spoken and will speak further on
clinical data and their experiences in
providing care they provided their
reasons for wanting to restrict the
delivery of a pregnant mother with
high-risk concerns of malpresentation or
breach multifetal or twin presentation
gestations and a trial of labor after
three cesarian sections to be undertaken
at a should be undertaken at a hospital
setting I wholeheartedly agree with
these statements I would like to offer
another view of this matter there's
already a rift in some areas between the
community midwives and Physicians some
Community midwives and their patients
have a distrust in the formal medical
system feeling that many interventions
are unwarranted or
unnecessary some hospital-based
providers have been on the receiving end
of Out of Hospital births gone wrong
only to find that the time to safely
intervene had passed sometimes resulting
in a damaged baby or worse and other
times mothers and fathers with emotional
scars that will last a
lifetime passing this bill would allow
community- based midwives to care for
patients with extremely high risks to
mother and baby outside of the safety
net of a hospital this will lead to more
intrapartum emergencies and transfers to
facilities where there might already be
a bias against the outof hospital birth
population this would further tarnish
the relationship between the community
midwives and the OB units where they
present when they present only when
things have gone wrong it would
undermine the trust that is developed in
many communities amongst the community
midwives and their local OB providers
and
hospitals why should we knowingly allow
some of the most high-risk issues In
Obstetrics to be cared for without a
safety net as a practicing OBGYN each of
these conditions warrants a hospital
care and continuous monitoring of the
baby and mother to ensure a safe birth
process which is what we all want to do
anything different would be negligent on
the part of those facilitated
it perhaps an analogy might make it
clear we can agree that a baby is
perhaps anyone's most precious belonging
or commodity parents would step in front
of bullets or Bears or buses to prevent
from any harm occurring to their baby or
child just as most car rides are
uneventful and end with a safe arrival I
believe that the majority of lowrisk
births can be similarly accomplished
safely with good labor support and
without extra or undue medical attention
yet we still put our babies in car seats
to get them for point A to point B not
because we're expecting a car accident
but so our child can be safe in the
event of one then add a snowstorm like
the one we had last week you better
believe that most parents would not go
out in that storm but if it were
absolutely necessary they would make
sure their baby was strapped tightly and
securely in that car seat just in case
please start wrapping up allowing out of
the hospital birth attempts have breach
babies twin pregnancies and vaginal
deliveries after multiple C-section
without the safety net of the hospital
and all it can provide is an eem in an
emergency it's like driving your baby
out in a snowstorm without a car seat it
would be negligent to do so House Bill
101 goes against all that we do to keep
mothers and babies safe during the labor
process in our state I'm adamantly
opposed to this thank you thank you any
you also signed up to speak is Dr Emy
Lee representing
minutes hi my name is Amy Lee I'm a New
Hampshire resident and also a resident
OBGYN physician I'm additionally
speaking on behalf of the New Hampshire
Medical Society as
well I'm here today to oppose
hb1010 I want to disclose that this
testimony contains content that may be
triggering to survivors of birth
trauma New Hampshire's a relatively
rural state with expanding maternity
care deserts a major factor influencing
the safety of a pled home birth is the
availability of Safe And Timely transfer
during labor or
postpartum the reported risk of needing
transport to a hospital during labor is
up to 37% for firsttime moms and 10% for
women who have had babies
before in areas like New Hampshire
without a health system built for home
births and where the Receiving Hospital
may be remote there is the potential for
delayed or prolonged transport during
labor postpartum this will ultimately
result in higher rates of death for
mothers and
infants now let's add the highrisk
scenarios of long-distance travel while
in labor postpartum to hb1010
scenarios I'll illustrate some scenarios
that can and will happen if hb1010 goes
into
effect imagine a baby is being born
breach meaning feet or butt first the
head is the biggest part that must pass
through the Eternal bony pelvis which
means the space between the hips let's
say the body comes out but the head gets
caught what happens is that the
umbilical cord gets compressed between
the infant's head and the maternal bony
pelvis cutting off the infant's oxygen
supply the infant
asphyxiates the mother then needs to be
transported potentially hours with her
dead infant half
delivered if the patient were in the
hospital or very close
forceps or a cesarian could have
urgently been performed to potentially
save this
baby twins carry a higher risk for
breach presentation and are therefore at
risk for what I just described what is
also concerning about twins is that they
have an 18-fold higher risk of
postpartum Hemorrhage than single infant
births Hemorrhage can happen in minutes
patients experiencing postpartum
Hemorrhage require medications pressure
induction devices and even rarely H
hysterectomies many need intravenous
fluids and blood transfusions to keep
them stable until the bleeding can be
stopped these resources are simply not
available at home births and a patient
could easily bleed to death over long
transport
distances it is not hard to imagine a
scenario where an ambulance arrives
saturated in blood with a dead
mother I understand the sponsor's goals
to improve access to Midwife care for
patients throughout the state but but
hb1010 is not the
way enacting the spill and disregarding
the reality of Health Systems in New
Hampshire will result in maternal and
infant
deaths for these reasons I urge the
committee to recommend itl for
hb1010 okay perfect timing the minutes
just ended any questions representative
Merchant thank you Mr
chairman I'm sort of torn somewhat if I
understand the issue of free birthing
and that seems to be something that
women want to gravitate towards that in
itself has a set of risk associated with
it balancing that with ones that have
access to a nurse Midwife which also has
risk associated with it I'm trying to
figure out how do we somehow ensure that
those who want free birthing have some
access some care and not something all
of a sudden it's done at the very last
minute through an amess ride which may
not be called for so how do we somehow
balance the two ends yeah that's a good
question there are other places in the
world and even other states that have
very Integrated Health Systems meaning
that they have rules and regulations set
up with specific criteria for when to
transfer during labor or postpartum to a
facility and many of those facilities
are within close distance when example
is in Washington state they do home
births of low risk I'm not talking about
these high-risk scenarios but they do
home more home births there but the
average distance from the hospital there
miles and in terms I would say in terms
of the people who want free birth I'm
not sure this bill is going to find
providers out there who are willing to
take on all these highrisk scenar I I
don't think it will address the problem
of people wanting to do home free births
I think there's other ways to do that
and I think um people have spoken before
have brought up great points including
like let's have a conversation on how we
can do more breach deliveries but this
is not the way you have a followup I
think you've answered the question I'm
trying to again balance the free
birthing movement if you will and their
rights to do free birthing but still
have access somewhat to some medical
care if they elect to do that and that's
what I'm not sure where to go with it
but thank you for what you what you
provided to me I can look at what's
going on in Washington some of the
integrated care because there are two
sets of um risk factors in either
scenario other
questions seeing no other questions
thank
you also signed up to speak is
representative Kelly
Penza representative Penza you've asked
I'm here in support of this bill because
I'm I support I support choice and it's
been um my oldest is 17 since uh I had
them and I had them in a hospital but
I'm just going to use my personal
experience so I come from a family of
big babies and um so I was 10 and a half
pounds my brother was almost 11 and so
they said I was going to have big babies
and they um wanted to schedule me a
C-section and all of those types of
things the pushing level of of surgical
procedures is huge and I could give a
hundred
stories of fellow mom friends that were
in those same
situations and so I'm sure that the you
know maybe this bill would be amended I
just believe that that it shouldn't be a
disqualifying Factor just because
because a you know a mom had a C-section
or two a lot of these people were pushed
into having them one they make a lot
more money than having it just be you
know in a hospital we know that for a
fact and I just my personal experience
is having that level of choice so I I
would hope that there would be uh you
know something that comes forward to to
support this effort um I think there was
a lot of stat Ms that were said that are
just not true in regards with Midwifery
and and things like that it's one of the
oldest professions um on the on the
planet so before we had hospitals and
all these big huge fancy um things
babies have been delivered in homes
which are different than free births
home births have been happening for a
long time for you know hundreds of years
so one of the doctors that spoke here uh
I saw for about four years and he used
to wear a button that said I trust women
and I think we have to trust women thank
you thank you any
you also signed up to speak is Dr
Cecilia Clemens representing
herself and you've asked a little over
three minutes the closer to three
minutes you can make it the better thank
you good afternoon
my name is Dr Cecilia Clemens I'm a
board certified OBGYN I am the Dartmouth
Manchester OB division chair and the
section chief of OBGYN at Catholic
Medical Center I've been delivering
babies in the state of New Hampshire
since
1997 I've worked with midm midwives my
entire career I collaborate with
midwives both in the hospital setting
and when accepting transfers from out of
Hospital midwives who are attempting out
of Hospital births I deeply respect
respect their practice and value the
Midwife physician collaboration to
provide the best Maternal Fetal and
neonatal
outcomes I am a proponent of vaginal
birth including for those women with
twin gestations
malpresentation and those who have
undergone multiple prior cesarian births
I disagree with previous testimony that
the state of New Hampshire does not
allow hospitals in the state of New
Hampshire do not allow C SEC vaginal
bursts after two three C sections come
to
CMC I disagree that vaginal breaches are
not allowed come to CMC I teach them we
do them and people who have sat in this
chair saying that they are not allowed
in the state of New Hampshire are wrong
I'm speaking today in opposition of
House Bill
1010 the American College of nurse
midwives states that midwives must
provide complete accurate and accessible
information for patients to make
informed Healthcare decisions patients
who desire ire home birth should review
evidence-based information on its risks
and benefits from their Midwife patients
should be informed that although planned
home birth is associated with fewer
maternal interventions than planned
Hospital birth it is also associated
with a more than two-fold increased risk
of perinatal death and a three-fold
increased risk of neonatal seizures and
severe neurologic dysfunction a recent
study showed that home labor after ceran
was associated with an intrapartum fetal
death rate of 3 per th
as compared to13 per thousand in the
hospital setting this statistic
highlights the home labor after cesarian
would increase neonatal morbidity in the
state of New Hampshire why would the
legislature want to create a policy that
increases infant deaths in New Hampshire
while a woman who has had a prior
cesarian delivery is not a good
candidate for home bursts other
pregnancies are good candidates recent
studies report comparable perinatal
mortality rates among planed home and
Hospital burst describe the use of
strict selection criteria for
appropriate candidates these criteria
include absence of pre-existing maternal
disease a single fetus in the head down
position at term in the absence of Prior
uterine surgery including previous
cerian delivery let me
summarize based on population data and
rulings from the governing body of
Obstetricians fetal malpresentation
multiple gestation prior ceran delivery
are all absolute contraindications to
home birth House Bill 1010 explicitly
rejects Decades of evidence based
research and dismisses the governing
body from Eternal safety in the United
States of America when it proclaims that
there shall be no rules limiting Care by
a midwife for women with these
conditions I have personally been
involved up pleas multiple examples of
Hospital transfers for women who have
attempted an out of Hospital birth these
examples unfortunately have concluded
with neonatal transfers to tertiary care
centers with separation of moms and
babies interuterine and neonatal deaths
maternal hemorrhages due to uterine
damage requiring hysterectomy and not
insignificant birth trauma for mothers
after their emergent unexpected and
unprepared transfers to the hospital
every word of House Bill 1010 rejects
safety and will increase the deaths of
moms and infants in New Hampshire this
bill is terrifying and should be opposed
thank you thank you any questions
representative Shapiro and then
representative tez thank you Mr chairman
um you said that you were a supporter of
midwives and um and of patients having
choice so let's say there was somebody
who had a
certified what is it a certified
professional Midwife and they had formed
a trusting relationship with them and
then sometime in the third trimester um
a high-risk situation emerged and either
because the laws that stands or because
the Judgment of the um of the soon to be
mother and the Midwife they decided to
transfer their care to a hospital to you
um so to what in that case what to what
extent would
the Midwife who had a a good
relationship with the mom to be to what
extent would they be welcomed into the
hospital process would they you know in
what to what ENT and in what Manner
might they be able to be involved in the
birth in the hospital that's a great
question I take phone calls very
frequently at on call at the hospital
from out of hos out of Hospital midwives
who are asking to transfer patients to
the hospital sometimes they call
sometimes they don't call I always
encourage them in that discussion to
present with the patient for a a a
personto person handoff I always uh
invite them to stay and act as a support
person in a hospital obviously an out of
Hospital Midwife does not have hospital
privileges and can't act as a clinician
but they are more than encouraged to
stay and and bridge that relationship
with the hospital setting and and um and
and the person that they've been caring
for I absolutely am 100% uh a advocate
for um midwives staying
involved representative TZ and then
representative
Weber uh thank you uh Mr chairman and um
thank you Dr Clemens for taking my
question so uh prior
uh speakers have reminded us that for
Millennia women have been giving birth
at home so I was wondering and thank you
for explaining that it's and other
people also explaining it's less about
the role and it's more about about the
setting um that that that is really
important so can you can you remind us
or paint a picture of what the birth
outcomes were like historically versus
current day because none of us were
alive and we don't really
remember how much you know how many
women died how many babies died you know
what these these outcomes that happened
all the time that were considered the
norm that are very different from what
now you you know I I don't think I am
saying something that is unknown to to
this committee that
the Maternal Fetal outcomes in the
United States of America is almost at
the bottom of the of the
list um to answer your question what's
what's different in all of a millennia
is that we were in a a developing
country we had to accept a perinatal
mortality of
152% that is no longer acceptable in the
United
States how can we how can we as a
country say that it is okay
for us to make rules that increase risk
babies and correct we we haven't always
we they've been delivering out of
hospitals for
Millennia correct we'
also hopefully have decreased the
maternal and Fetal and neonatal
Weber thank you and thank you for taking
my question uh I think our mind is a
followup perhaps to representative
Shapiro um you stated that a mid a
certified professional Midwife coming
into the hospital with a patient would
not have hospital privileges and
therefore would be a support person but
not a clinician so my question is do you
have in your practice certified
professional midwives or do you have
only nurse midwives and as a hospital
practice Y in our hospital we have
certified nurse midwives who are
advanced practice providers who master's
degrees nursing degrees and master's
degrees so you don't have Affiliated um
certified professional M cor thank you
representative McLean yeah thank you Mr
chair thank you for taking my question
so um whenever you're working with a
patient you know we hear from all the
different doctors who testified you know
we make our recommendations and as a
doctor you you can recommend but you
can't
command and so there are going to be
some women who are going to you know in
spite of your counsel they're going to
kind of choose their own path and maybe
that involves a home birth um and so
kind of the testimony that I'm hearing
it almost sounds like these women are
kind of cut loose so and there's there's
no real place it's it's either you're
all in or you're all out kind of thing
and that kind of following on some are
representative Merchants concern so if
if you look at this bill is there
anything about this bill that you would
maybe Salvage to give these women a
softer place to land or anything else
that you would maybe recommend well I
mean I agree with the ongoing need for
discussion and I I agree with your
initial statement that you know it is
our job as as as as Physicians and
providers of of women's health is to
give information and women absolutely
are able to make their own
decisions and I work in a practice where
I have women come after four C-sections
three C-sections breach Mal PR you know
everything that we're talking about
today and try to have a risk benefit
discussion providing patient autonomy
they get to take the information that I
give them and make a decision and when
they make that decision it is my job to
support them in that decision and even
if it's not something that I would
personally choose
myself I am the physician that will
support them and my staff will support
them so I recently delivered someone who
had had four previous cesarian sections
who did not want repeat she came from a
home
Midwife and she
attempted a vaginal birth it we
supported her through that process and
ultimately she required a C-section
ultimately she asked for a C-section she
was in the supportive environment I
think that what we're talking about
there's nothing in the bill as it stands
to answer your question that I support
but I believe that there needs to be
ongoing discussion there needs to be
ongoing education with our public to
understand that women do have options
they can come to hospitals and be cared
for by midwives in a and and have that
safety
net any other
questions seeing none okay thank you
thank
you also signed up to speak is Emily bur
representing
herself and you've asked for three
minutes good afternoon committee chair
and committee members my name is Emily
bur and I'm a resident of Lebanon New
Hampshire I'm a certified nurse Midwife
and the director of the midwif re
service at Dartmouth Hitchcock Medical
Center I've been practicing as a
certified nurse Midwife since 2014
during my career I've attended births
both in the hospital sending and at a
birth center located outside of the
hospital I'm here to speak in opposition
of House Bill 1010 I'm concerned this
bill will put birthing people their
babies and The Midwives who care for
them at risk this bill under undermines
and compromises my own my own
profession's ability to uphold the
quality and safety of the care we
provide us midwives and it undermines
the New Hampshire Midwifery Council and
established Midwifery certifying
organizations who set our standards of
practice based on expertise and data
this bill goes against expert
practitioners advice on who is a good
candidate for home birth while I'm a
certified nurse Midwife and therefore
not regulated by the Midwifery Council I
share much of the same philosophy
training and fundamentals of approach as
certified midwives and have deep respect
for them as a midwife I strongly believe
in the process of normal birth I
strongly support support reducing
barriers to accessing Midwifery care
including access to nurse midwives and
certified professional midwives
including things like improving
insurance coverage and financial support
for Midwifery Services increasing
programs that educate and train midwives
I also believe that home birth is a safe
and great option for many birthing
people but I do not believe it is a safe
option for all birthing people research
shows that home in the US is a safe
option for people who are low risk I
think hb1010 is too broad in terms of
who it endorses as a good candidate for
home birth as a Dartmouth as a midwife
at Dartmouth Hitchcock Medical Center
I'm happy to provide Midwife free care
to people who have had two prior cerian
sections and desire a vaginal birth with
the support of the obgy in Physicians
and anesthesiologist who work in the
hospital with me people with two prior
C-sections as others have said are at
higher risk of complic ations like
uterine rupture if a uterine rupture
occurs a woman and her baby need
immediate access to Anesthesia a
C-section delivery most likely blood
products and a neonatal intensive care
Team all of which are immediately
available where I practice minutes
matter in these cases my Professional
Organization the American College of
nurse midwives states that the safety of
home birth is optimized by assessing the
appropriateness of the woman and family
for home birth attendance by a qualified
maternity care provider which I believe
believe includes CNM and cpms and
Integrated Systems that support
collaborative care in summary I oppose
hb1010 and recommend it be reviewed to
ensure it truly upholds patient autonomy
the right to inform decision and upholds
the highest clinical standards of midwif
free Care thank you okay thank you any
questions representative mlan thank you
Mr chair just a quick question I didn't
get your name Emily burce I have a
written statement that I did not
that I have copies of that I can thank
you do you have enough for the whole
committee or yes okay you can send that
okay okay sure representative Lon uh
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question I apologize IID had
to go chair a subcommittee on
Alzheimer's so I didn't hear everything
that was here um my question is in my
experience when I had a brief preach
presentation on my third child after
rapid births for all of them I was told
that I would be unable to I would be
required to have a cesarian unless I had
um a very fast birth like I had with the
others where they didn't have time to
prep me for surgery in your practice are
you able to deliver breach
babies I as a certified nurse Midwife do
not currently deliver breach babies
because I haven't had the experience or
exposure or training to feel confident
in that area but I know that there are
Physicians within the Dartmouth Health
System who do feel skilled in that area
and can make that available to patients
who want that thank
you all right representative
Missour thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question um I heard you say at
the beginning you said maybe I heard it
wrong um did when you you said birthing
people can you please clarify what that
what that includ who that includes I
think so not all birthing people
identify as
women and we support birthing people
other questions representative
Shapiro yes thank you Mr chairman um
we've heard testimony um equally
um that breach babies are not delivered
vaginally in New Hampshire and then
we've heard from
several Physicians or from you as a uh
nurse Midwife that they are
um
any any ideas about why there's
the that those differences and ideas
about what exists and what doesn't
exist I'm sure other people could
comment on that as well but I think it
goes back to the training and experience
of the individual provider and the team
that they're working on it is in some
way a dying art I think many people
historically were very comfortable
providing breach birth and midwives in
many settings are those providers as
well I've worked around the world where
midwives do breach deliveries I've
worked in Africa where women where
midwives do breach deliveries um and
that's the standard of practice but I
think in the United States we don't a
lot of providers don't have the training
to feel comfortable offering that as an
option but some
do
followup I guess I'm wondering more
about
why why there's a very different
perception
among the medical providers that talked
about this as an option and other people
who are testifying that may be an
impossible question to answer but I'm
I'm we're hearing two different truths
as we often do and I'm wondering if you
could shed any light on why we're
hearing
that um I think that is a difficult
question to answer I imagine there may
be parts of the state where the nearest
provider who feels comfortable in doing
a vaginal breach is
far away or potentially difficult to
access other
minutes hello my name is Nicole roach I
currently work as a doula midwif re
assistant assistant and I am also a
nurse uh in the time I have been
attending births I have attended a
variety of births in different settings
all across the country in various
different states where the law is
different in all of them so I've seen um
many different home births that don't
necessarily happen here in New
Hampshire um most of the births I have
attended have been at home under the
care of a
Midwife I have seen women birth Twins
and breach either footling breach or you
know butt first feet first safely at
home I have also attended births where
women have had multiple cesarian
sections prior to choosing to have a
baby at home under the care of a
midwife these women have done so safely
as well I have actually attended a lot
of births in other states that would
have been illegal in the state of New
Hampshire occasionally women in New
Hampshire even choose to leave the state
to have their babies in States like
Massachusetts so they can have a safe
home birth that they Desire with a
skilled
Midwife everything mentioned in this
bill is considered a variation of normal
um I know after some of the testimony of
some of the
Obstetricians um apparently there is a
little bit of a rift in who considers
What A variation of normal but to me and
in my experience attending births in
hospital birth centers and at home
breach Twins and you know vack are all
variations of normal and can absolutely
be attended safely by midwives in the
home setting midwives all over the world
are attending births like this safely at
home midwife directly south of us in
States like Massachusetts and
Connecticut are attending births like
this safely at home most of my clients
from out of state are shocked when I
tell them that they would not be able to
have a skilled Midwife attend their
birth at home if they lived in New
Hampshire I was shocked too when I
learned about the restrictive nature of
Midwifery care in home birth in New
Hampshire most people I talk to
especially those people that live in
States like Massachusetts and
Connecticut are also very shocked about
the restrictions that we have here in
the state of New
Hampshire truthfully this bill goes
beyond
Midwifery this is women's
right women deserve the autonomy and the
respect to be able to evaluate the risks
and benefits between healthc care
providers and birth
settings because as many people know um
no choice you can make here goes without
any risk right you you choose to birth
in the hospital there's a risk there
choose to birth at home there's a risk
there there's always some level of Risk
please start wrapping up the passing of
this bill would be a measure of risk
reduction because under the current
restrictions women are either for forced
to have an unwanted Hospital birth I
refer to that as a risk because the
maternal death rate uh in the hospital
is actually higher than at home or their
other option is to have an unwanted
unassisted birth at home without the
care of a midwife I feel it is important
to mention that the passing of this bill
would not force a midwife to take a
client that she does not feel
comfortable with taking it only gives
midwives the freedom to work to the full
scope of their practice and to not have
to abandon their clients due to
variations of normal that they might be
comfortable dealing with there are
continuing educational resources
available for midwives to learn more
about these variations of normal and to
develop their skills the Coalition for
breach bth birth um breach without B
birders and twins trust are examples of
organizations that provide trainings for
doctors midwives nurses doulas and other
Healthcare Providers and birth
attendance as a woman a mother and a
birth professional I am very grateful
for this bill I think this is a positive
step in the right direction I hope there
are similar bills to follow that remove
the necessary restrictions surrounding
birth in New Hampshire so in closing I
am in support of this Bill thank you any
questions representative mlan thank you
Mr chair and thank you for taking my
question so um you mentioned experiences
that you have had in Massachusetts and
Connecticut yes um are you do you know
if the provisions that are being uh
proposed in this legislation are already
legal in Massachusetts or Connecticut
they are in both of those States
yes so I I was just going to say that
there's just less restrictions and
regulations in general in those
States other questions representative
Lon um thank you Mr chairman um are you
telling me that had my child not
returned back to a calic um the
presentation of head down I could have
actually fled the state of New Hampshire
and had the birth that I wanted safely
in another state to get that necessary
medical care I can't
100% say that it would be safe with no
complications of course um but there
would have been more than likely a
midwife in Massachusetts that would be
re willing to receive you as a client
and attend your birth and provide you
with Medical Care in a home setting you
know you need to get like an Airbnb or
something obviously if you were to leave
this state but yeah this absolutely I
have seen this happen and I have
attended births thank you that's good to
know should I end up in that situation
again
other questions representative
mlan uh thank you uh Mr chair actually
it's a question for you so I'm wondering
in light of that would it be possible to
maybe have the committee researcher
maybe do a side by side on that just to
confirm the details of
that sure um she's apparently not here
at the moment but yes Christina D are
there I don't think so yeah I'll check
whether on that
yeah give me a note on that or send me
an email or something okay any other
questions seeing none thank
you this again following up on
representative mcan's uh inquiry with
the chair I'd like to add to that inquir
with a research if we could um one of
the one of the industries that probably
knows about risk more than any one of us
is the insurance industry and I'd like
to look at the various insurance
policies and RIS format if you will
across various States because if there
are in fact variations in state law
there may be variations in liability
insurance because it's based upon risk
factors so if we're really trying to get
down to measuring risk a good place
maybe to look is the insurance industry
because if anyone knows risk and
monitors risk more than anyone else the
insurance industry sure did you get all
that
Christina okay all right any other
questions or comments seeing no thank
you thank you representative tees yeah
just to clarify I would propose that we
don't just look at Massachusetts right
that if you're going to compare what's
happening in other states that's
relevant it should be
comprehensive thank
you okay also signed up to speak and I
I'm not sure about this last name uh
Katherine
Brainard from Han branard
okay and you've asked for three minutes
um we need to leave shortly so please
keep it to three minutes my name is
Katherine Bramhall I'm a certified
professional Midwife in the state of
Vermont and New Hampshire I also serve
on the office of Professional Regulation
in the state of New Hampshire which is
the equivalent of the um New Hampshire
Midwifery Council I have I'm also the
owner of gentle Landing birth center in
Hanover New Hampshire which is 6/10 of a
mile from Buck on Buck Road from
Dartmouth from Dartmouth hospital I'm
here to OS the passing of this bill as
it's written what I want to say it there
are a few Corrections I'd like to
propose to testimony here based on my
profession and um my 17 years of being a
midwife and attending out of Hospital
births having received over 700 babies
in my hands and never having lost a
baby so H so I as we discuss this bill
this bill needs to be considered under
the offices of direct of the New
Hampshire Midwifery Council and the
women and The Midwives who actually um
would be performing any of these things
to their lure and to their um
experience I'm the head of an
international um disaster relief
organization that won CNN hero of the
Year award that is cpms that get called
to disaster areas in low resourced areas
where there are lots and lots of
unfortunate low low resourced
opportunities to have
babies what I want you to know is that
that women in lower resourced areas in
underdeveloped countries would give
anything for safeguards to be in place
those safeguards do not include the over
safeguarding quote unquote of OG of the
American College of of Obstetrics and
Gynecology that has superimposed their
idea of what is safe not really being
informed about what my profession's
training my it is not just about
attending a few bursts it's a three-year
it's a three-year Midwifery program of
some sort or another not just a high
school degree I consider that extremely
degrading for the reputation I have what
I also would like to say in testimony is
that the safety of breach the safety out
of in an out of hospital setting either
at home or in my birth center which is
not legal in my birth center we don't
have that but the safety of these of
these um of the pro proposals in this
bill have everything to do with not just
taking a class or not just you know
having a experience of one or two but to
have literally an experience inside when
you're in an out of Hospital setting
which you go this is okay the the true
experience of of and the true
conversation that needs to be had with
this the complicated nature of this bill
is how do we keep the resources
connected up with out of Hospital
midwives who really do know their stuff
I don't know an OB I have lots of OBGYN
friends who go I wouldn't have the steel
in my in my spine to do what you women
do so it so when when you're
investigating the the claims about cpms
I'm going to back up the Midwifery
Council that I belong to and say please
come to a meeting if you really do want
to have questions or email us the
questions and get accurate information
please start wrapping your testimonial
thank you I have one more thing to say
please sure um um as far as um risk goes
we hear lots and lots of Sensational
home birth
death um um examples during testimony
here as well as out in public The
Washington Post did that did that
article what you also are not hearing
and I really want as
as women have the option for autonomy in
this transformational time in their life
the conversation should not be stopped
simply because some Washington Post
reporter wrote something or some
OBGYN out there there's a famous OBGYN
who spends a lot of time um taking us
down what are the true what's the true
information and how do we weave women
and birthing families into this
conversation so that a complicated Bill
proposal can be actually re written or
considered with everybody's needs and
safety in in taking into consideration I
oppose this bill as it's written I hope
that this bill is opened up for further
conversation thank you any questions
representative Merchant quick one um in
regards to the certified professional
nurse midwives certified professional
Midwife I
apologize is there a particular
insurance company you folks use mostly
predominantly yes we are credentialed in
all not credential who's your insurance
carrier yeah we and we have liability of
1 million3 million which is required in
order to be credentialed with name of
compan I'm sorry is there name of the
company we we use Southern Cross as um
the it's medpro I think yes other
questions representative Murphy thank
you and thank you for taking my question
um so you are are you are adamantly
opposed to the bill as written as you
said is that BEC because I know where
your building is you are literally
neighbors to Dartmouth Hitchcock you
could throw a stone into their yard so
is it because it's not because of the
distance obviously from where you are to
having a backup source to take care of
any troubles you may have so is your
opposition to the bill based on the
indications uh for home delivery meaning
um you know multiple you know um uh
previous C-sections or breach
presentation or so I'm just trying to
understand why you were opposed because
I know that you are very very close to a
backup facility so is it is it
principally because of the indications
for home delivery that you oppose no I'm
opposed to the bill primarily
because
um um because the bill isn't written
accurately to address the things that
need to uh what um what I think it was
Beth who said there's not enough in the
bill that's written as it is to actually
what are the requirements that would
make it safe for you for me as a midwife
I mean I I I don't take chances like I'm
pretty conservative about what I do but
how do we build this in as a safety net
for both the mid The Midwives who are
certified and licensed in the state of
Vermont by the Midwifery Council to
protect the public as well as offer
choice so that over and over we've
talked about women don't just go sorry
I'm out of here because I'm just doing a
freeth we have to have this more
comprehensive for protection of
everybody and I also want to say that
massach the Massachusetts um comparison
is not an equal comparison they're not a
licensed state St so they don't have
rules and regulations just as you're
looking that up other
minutes
am I good okay good afternoon my name is
Jenny sweet I live in the White
Mountains of New Hampshire I am a single
mom to five boys Survivor of domestic
violence a Dua trainer educator and I
have been studying Midwifery in
physiological birth for over a decade we
cannot stay on this path because it is
not working over the past 25 years I
have just been gestating birthing and
raising my five boys and holding
families or holding space for fam
family's
birthing in the granite state thank you
so much for this opportunity to speak to
the committee today I am in favor of
hb1010 as I sit before you today as
somebody who has birthed five humans
walking away from the birth experience
with severe birth trauma I almost lost
my life due to the Egos and the bias of
providers one who is sitting behind me
right
now then I started sitting with hundreds
of birthing people in our state watching
the maternal Health crisis unfolds in
every location we cannot keep doing what
we are doing birth trauma and poor
outcomes is not just oh it was hard the
research now shows us that the safest
and healthiest way to birth a baby is
vaginally with trained
providers vaginal birth has a lifelong
impacts on the child and The Mother We
are playing God and we are harming our
community by by doing so if we look at
Birth in New Hampshire by numbers the
picture is clear I got the following
statistics off of the New Hampshire
Vital Statistics website this is the
data that we collect as midwives and
birth or and um providers off the back
of the birth certificate in
2023 12,080 babies were born nearly 25
of those babies recovered by Medicaid in
2020 27.4 of all births in New Hampshire
were by lowrisk cesarian section we
ranked 36th in the nation during that
time I attempted to get the latest
statistics off of the vital statistics
website for 2023 but unfortunately it
data in 2023
[Music]
1,745 baby 49 babies were born to
mothers who had had PRI U prior cesarian
section
five of those babies were born in
freestanding birth centers and 18 were
born at home 434 babies were born in the
non-vertex breach position in 2023
3,781 people were induced in the state
of New Hampshire another 3,058 people
had their labors augmented but not a
full induction 1,20 babies were born
with moonium staining and 1,66 babies
were admitted into the make you
7,72 babies were born with forceps if
you don't know what forceps are they
essentially take meat CLE like the
medieval things they wrap that around
your baby's head and they yank your baby
meat 11 of those babies born by first
steps were after the provider attempted
to deliver the baby with a vacuum in
2023 118 people were admitted into the
ICU and I was very interested to learn
that only 16 of those people were on
Medicaid we have an opportunity right
now to shift things in a New Direction
by giving power back to mothers and
midwives who feel comfortable attending
these variations of normal I urge you to
pass hb110 with some amendments we need
to keep these important conversations um
giving people giving Choice back to
people in the perinatal Community if
you're going to change the world it
starts with how babies come into it one
in six people experience preventable
birth trauma 80% of all pregnancy
related morbidity and mortality are
preventable the research shows us that
healthy mom and healthy baby with midwif
free care in out of Hospital
freestanding birth centers are the
safest way to bring babies into the
world again again breach Twins and
vbucks are variations of normal
regulating these births brings great
profits to the system and massive trauma
to our communities please start wrapping
up the average home birth um the average
home birth not covered by insurance will
cost around
$5,500 a medical induction that leads to
an unnecessary cesarian section due to a
Cascade of interventions runs upwards
towards 60 Grand did you know that the
number one cause of maternal mortality
in the new state of New Hampshire is
substance use yet a newborn's first
introduction two opiates is in uteral we
are using fenol it is the number one
pain medication used in labor and birth
right now' pleas stop wrapping up your
testim that to people ma'am please stop
testimony all these births believe me
that we the system is profiting off the
people and Ste stealing auton autonomy
from healthy mom and healthy baby and
then filtering them into a system that
is currently imploding and harming
people while the medical system tries to
fix something that is not broken and
then it let me stop you there are there
any questions um I see none thank you
thank you you've given us a lot of good
information thank
you okay I have no one else signed up to
testify this afternoon on
hb1010 uh two people did sign up in
favor of and 1 2 3 4 5 six signed up
against it in the blue sheet on the back
and online there are 106 people in
support and 26 opposed okay uh there are
no other bills to be heard this
afternoon so I'm closing the public
hearing on
you
I